your backpack
oh that could work
[Music]
this is getting hot
[Music]
ready
got it
okay
[Music]
me
victory is ours my friends hi lina
brigator oh my gosh you've grown
oh everyone this is me hi
everyone nice to meet you
does this mean overwatch is back
yes yes we are
we're being overrun null sector is
everywhere
i'll hold them as long as i can
what are you doing here it's happening
again
paris was just the beginning this is a
global invasion
so how's overwatch enjoyed our city it's
beautiful
except for all the killer robots
look up there that's the command ship
then we know what we have to do oh
yeah you're with me we're getting aboard
that ship
i knew you would return one day it has
been too long
master i can't do this
you've made your choice nobody will stop
us
trouble is cropping up all over the
world
it's not just no sector a lot of lives
are riding on what we do next
we'll have to fight one city at a time
[Music]
let's treat them i've got you papa
watching your back now that's teamwork
time to learn some new tricks
[Music]
[Music]
do not worry i will push it
okay other direction i
am good at pushing things
sojourn here
welcome everybody to blizzcon we know
that you all want to hear more about
overwatch 2.
[Music]
allow us to invite you behind the scenes
to explain more of what we're doing and
why
everybody please hit record fingers
crossed we lost scott
it's off to a good start this is going
great
we've been assembling one of the best
teams that i have ever worked with
i'm nervous and i'm so proud
of the progress that we have made
together
we really liked the stylized drop down
imagine that
it's coming forward boom boom this
starts to spin the scale and the scope
of this game
have meant that we've needed to grow
substantially just have we have to
sorry let me start overall i think we've
done
incredibly well as team moving to work
from home
oh she had a play there have definitely
been challenges
but the team is really putting
everything we've got behind this game
to me it's the next big step in the
overwatch universe
new heroes game modes major story beats
with competitive and pve i see overwatch
2 as the overwatch for all of my friends
you know we're always inspired by what
story and franchise development does
with their animated shorts
we really wanted to bring that cinematic
experience into the game
you can invest in your heroes and grow
them over time
i'm super geeked out about overwatch too
i can't wait for people to play this
game it just gets better and better
there are some things that we just can't
do without a sequel
so thank you so much for your patience
so far
and i hope you enjoyed this behind the
scenes look
at overwatch 2.
all of our players at home they want to
see one of the new maps
that we've never talked about before
really i can just like
i can just talk about anything that i
want to
yeah you're serving this up to the guy
that is like
unintentionally leaked information and
past
interviews you can do it officially now
okay so one of the maps that i'm
i'm most excited for in overwatch 2 is
our roam
map
we always want overwatch to feel like
this globetrotting adventure for our
players
so we're having a lot of fun coming up
with the overwatch version of rome
we wanted a very romantic sort of this
powerful feeling of old world
architecture
one of the most exciting things for me
is the early building of these maps
where we get to sit down together with
key people from the environment team
level designers
effects groups we'll spend some time
talking about moments in the game
that we really want to see like the
colosseum or a grand view of the hills
of rome in the backdrop
and then we'll go back and do a paint
over or we'll do a concept painting of
certain things based on that
we try to draw inspiration from as many
different
sources as possible for example one of
our environment artists had just taken a
trip
to rome and he returned with thousands
of pictures and was so excited
to work on a map set in italy there's a
lot of ancient architecture in rome that
represents the empire that it used to be
so
we brought some of that back some of the
things that are destroyed in real life
we kind of rebuilt in a kind of
overwatch style it's one of the most
beautiful pieces of environment art that
i think we've made
for the entire game and it just
absolutely took my breath away
can we reveal more maps yes scott
scott why don't you have the honor why
don't you reveal
like is there an artifact like let's
pick an artified one
i know what map i want to talk about
it's the one that i just get super
excited about new york city
new york city is just an amazing
overwatch location
we're really striving to make it as
authentic as possible while still
putting this overwatch spin on it
there's a lot of amazing buildings and
architecture pieces that just especially
for artists stands out a lot
and they usually use this kind of art
deco style from the 1920s 1950s
we started in an area that's a little
bit like the village
there's some smaller shops there there's
a fire station
little pizza places and things that
people that are familiar
with new york city will either recognize
or maybe
see the reference that we're trying to
make with some of our different
locations
it feels like something you haven't seen
in other games before because it's
uniquely overwatch
[Music]
well we should move on otherwise we just
have to reveal
more maps so we were talking about pvp
and you know one thing that i think is
really
interesting about pvp in overwatch too
is some of the philosophical changes
we're making to the approach
pvp feels different new we're upgrading
our combat feel
the roles are playing differently when
it comes to all new maps
it's a pretty big departure from where
we are
on live right now so i i can't wait to
see where we end up with it by the time
we launch this thing
we're also experimenting with the idea
we call roll passives which are passive
abilities that a hero can have
based on what role they are for example
currently in our internal builds
the tank heroes all have knockback
reduction against them
and they also generate less ultimate
charge for enemies they're shooting at
them
damage dealing heroes have a movement
speed bonus which is great for
flanking around the map and uh healing
heroes support heroes have
automatic healing that kicks in after
they haven't taken damage for a while
very similar to mercy's passive but a
little bit of a lower rate
one of the more shocking changes that
we've been exploring
in overwatch 2 pvp is it that's
applied to all of the tanks we want to
try to make them
more toe-to-toe brawlers and less
characters that just stand back and
protect other people
so for example for reinhardt we've given
him two charges of fire strikes we can
throw
fire strikes a lot more aggressively and
more often also his charge
he's able to cancel it now and you can
steer it more aggressively so you can
you know not quite turn a corner but you
can definitely more accurately pin
targets and because you can cancel it it
allows you to use it much more
aggressively and
you know really go after those key
targets without feeling like you're
going to sacrifice
you know all of your positioning
everything to get there he's almost more
terrifying now with us to be able to
unleash his full arsenal
more often than just being the guy with
a shield
the changes to reinhardt that we're
trying and
they might not shift that's just the
reality but the changes
that we're trying right now are to try
to embrace
more of that instinct that players have
when they want to play
a big burly character that looks
aggressive
and feels like it should be aggressive
shortly after blizzcon we we spun up
this group our combat feel group
um to really just work on what happens
when a player holds the trigger we're
putting a ton of effort into
looking at all of our characters and
trying to
give them even a more visceral weapon
feel
from sound to vfx to animation
to the design of these units all new
sounds for
for a lot of our weapons in the game and
a whole new sound system
that's driving it and we didn't just
level up a unit
we leveled up the rest of the game
when we first started working on
overwatch you know we spent quite a bit
of time working on
gunfire sounds and just just general
combat feel to make it feel really
awesome
we're revisiting pretty much everything
nothing's off the table so we're looking
at
even kind of small things such as quick
melee attacks that every hero has so
they have kind of new audio paths and a
new kind of
feel and the visual effect we hit things
one of the bigger efforts we're
undertaking for overwatch 2
is what we're calling our weapon 2.0
sound pass
what this is a big overhaul systems in
the game
that means the way the gun feels in your
hands you could feel the ammo running
out
as you're getting lower on the clip
we've really tried to amplify those
sounds
to better encapsulate the gameplay and
the gun play that comes
with overwatch too
another key for the weapons was getting
them to feel like they're in the
environment this meant working with
convolution reverb it's a new system
that we've implemented into overwatch
it's a way that we can
capture the acoustics of an environment
and transport it
onto the sounds that we're using so we
went and captured tales
of guns in different environments
through our weapon shoots
and then we've cut them and applied it
so that we can support a lot more
environments
now we're sporting outdoor urban
outdoor warehouse tales
tight tunnels small rooms and it gives a
lot more presence to the weapons in the
way that they react
in the world the shooter genre has
evolved a lot since overwatch one came
out
on top of that i think we really want to
push the visceral nature of how we do
combat
so we focused a lot not just on the
wonderful sound effects but
also with how the the gun moves as you
shoot you know so you can really feel
every single shot leaving the chamber
and there's a lot of subtle little
tweaks we have to do
on the gameplay engineering side to make
that feel really visceral
everything from making sure that the
camera shakes are crisp
making sure that if you get shot you
know exactly these tight indicators show
up on the outside of your reticle
all these things play into making the
game feel not just
tight and responsive but also modern and
up to date
take 76 for example what we wanted to do
in overwatch 2 with his weapon was to
make it really
feel incredibly powerful and that
happens with a bunch of different
elements that mix together
but it really feels like the gun is
almost just outside of your control
a lot of that comes down to this camera
shake technology where every set every
time you fire the weapon
you want to feel like it's running
through your entire body and the camera
shake gives that extra bite to every
single shot out of the chamber
it makes him feel really great you guys
got a sneak peek of
sojourn from last blizzcon she's been
under development for quite a while and
she's actually quickly at this point
become
a lot of people's favorites in-house
when we look back at
overwatch when it was originally created
there was a lot of heroes that were made
from a gameplay standpoint kind of
surrounding
a weapon type for example pharah was
based on a rocket launcher hero
widowmaker is clearly like kind of a
sniper we thought there was a weapon
that was kind of
missing that would be a lot of fun to
play with and that's a railgun it's so
much fun in the playtest to have this
really powerful shot that can
you know rip through enemies if you
really are accurate with it and she's
just all about the name skill so
if you got the name skull you'll love
her we're still exploring new game modes
and we're also reevaluating
older game modes that people are more
critical of
you know we're of the mindset maybe
maybe 2cp doesn't exist in overwatch 2.
and maybe there's a new cool game mode
that replaces it
we really want overwatch 2 to feel like
the next evolution a true sequel
to the first game not an add-on
it's not a small part it's not an
extension
of the original game this is an
evolution and a replacement to the
original game
and i think it's exciting
hero missions are probably one of the
things that's the hardest to wrap your
head around
if you've never played one of them
the goal around hero missions is for
these to be
this co-op pve experience
i personally only play competitive mode
like i'm all about that competition
and i have friends that they don't want
to do that at all so i'm really looking
forward to a game that i can play
hours and hours with with my friends who
aren't in competitive and it's also
something that i'm
interested in hero missions are the
content that people are playing
as they are leveling up their heroes and
so for
a system like this to really sing you
need
a lot of mission we don't want players
who feel like they're just in this grind
to get to the top
and there's a lot of really really good
back end technology that we're exploring
so the heroes are constantly bringing
their personality
and some light story to these hero
missions as well
the goal is to make as many as possible
hundreds of hero missions
we've explored a lot of different ways
of getting
to that much content so have like
different sets of enemy units that
people
will be fighting against and there's
different hero mission types
at the same time hero missions can take
place in all of the multiplayer maps
that we've done
and we're also adding new spaces onto
some of these maps
it's a huge challenge for the art team
we take maps that
a lot of people love and recognize and
we have to add a lot more
art and level design to it in this one
hero mission play test
we came up to an area in king's row that
usually has a gate on it
suddenly that gate opened and i saw a
new area of king's row that i had never
seen before you may be playing a payload
game type
and the payload may decide to take this
new route instead of
going the usual route that was really
really cool it was like this
eye-opening special moment
lan our lead tech artists on the
environment side
very early on our own free time made a
prototype
of a sandstorm on the temple of anubis
map and at the time we didn't know what
we wanted to do with that but it looked
awesome
we looked at it and went oh my god we
absolutely have to do this
so we put some new technology in place
that allows us to do this dynamically
you'd start the mission off clear day
midway through the mission suddenly this
sandstorm or heavy weather would show up
it made the world just feel so much more
alive
there's a sunset daytime nighttime but
depending on where you are in the world
these look different
california or hollywood would have what
we call a california sun
new bonnie there's a great african sun
that happens there
you start to get a sense of space and
mood this is what really
brings the levels to life for me the
dynamic world's exciting just seeing
these dramatic
landscapes the wind and the atmosphere
blowing by
it's a much more cinematic experience
for the player
before you start a mission you look at a
map it's nighttime in
necropolis or there's a sandstorm in
necropolis
players can make some comp choices based
on knowing this information
characters like hanzo or widowmaker
start to be a little more valuable
because they have
abilities that allow them to see through
the sand more clearly
are we going to talk about any of the
types of objectives
in hero missions yeah let's let's talk
about the objectives
players are being asked to do different
things from one hero mission to the next
so that they all feel really fresh
to the player for example we have
gathering return where you're trying to
go and grab these different canisters to
kind of safeguard them so they don't go
off and affect the population in a
negative way
it creates this really cool tension in
the world where on the one hand you're
trying to split up and go grab all these
canisters to be as efficient as possible
but at the same time now you're having
these sort of special enemy units spawn
that are really difficult and if you
kind of get caught by yourself
it turns into a pretty bad situation
really quickly it feels extremely
cooperative and like a very different
way to interact with the overwatch
universe
we're experimenting with all sorts of
ideas and just internally we have names
like
wall of death scavenger hunt and kill
quests and
all these new mechanics and enemies for
people to experience
players will be able to jump in night
after night play different hero missions
and then work through the progression
system leveling up their heroes
[Music]
at blizzcon in 2019 we started to talk
about progression
and we showed the very early version
of our talent system which i think was
really cool we had that one talent where
like
mate became the rolling snowball which
was a big hit
we've really blown that system out i'm
real excited about talents you can play
the same hero in so many different ways
now with the skill tree
you can have fun every night doing
different things and kind of
experimenting
yeah the talent system is like really
deep
and rich and every single hero has
different trees
you might open up 76's tree and as
you're leveling
and picking new talents you're starting
to feel your hero change
we've had some pretty hilarious versions
of the healing one where
his biotic field travels with him it
also repulses enemies we call it the
snowplow build
where 76 is like running through spaces
pushing enemies away from them
designing these is super fun because
it's like we get to break all the rules
that we've sort of established for
ourselves and
we get to really take the gloves off and
do crazy things like junkrat can do
wheeled grenade launchers and
we've had mercy be able to area effect
rez their whole team at once at super
long range
through walls it's been a ton of fun
kind of like mad scientists making all
this stuff
you're all used to using these kind of
kinetic weapons like soldier 76's rifle
or fire attack like what reinhardt's
flame strike does
as soon as you start to mutate these
things with talents all of a sudden
maybe you're doing
freeze damage or electrical damage but
it gives the animators a bunch of crazy
opportunities you know the animations
are going to change to show them
freezing and shattering
and if you you know shock someone with a
lighting attack it can shake in place
it's done maybe chained to other enemies
all sorts of stuff to make you feel like
you're controlling the battlefield
in novel ways as a huge rpg nerd myself
the first time i opened up the talent
tree systems it was like
oh my gosh this is this is speaking my
love language like
i just want to plan and i want to see
like where do i want to invest
and how am i going to play this
character yes it's so great you like
you start at the bottom of the tree like
oh my gosh exactly like tracer gets to
do
what and then you start working and kind
of planning how you're going to get down
there
it's like ah that's so fun
when we look back at blizzcon 2019
and we talk about some of the criticisms
that we had
one of them as a development team that
we felt was that the combat
was just not engaging enough so the fact
that our combat
wasn't highly engaging to us as players
meant that we had a problem with the
enemy units
and that they just weren't feeling
interesting enough
just because we show something to the
public it doesn't mean that that is what
it's going to be if we make discoveries
where
things aren't working how we want
they're not reading how we want they're
not fun enough
we're totally down to reinvestigate
reiterate and just
really find ways to level kind of all
aspects of things until they feel good
i would say a major focus of all of
2020 was to make the null
sector enemy units more engaging and
some of this was
adding new units and evolving other
units that we had
interesting combat for us is varied
combat for us
so sometimes we're going to ask you to
protect something
in overwatch too sometimes we're just
going to ask you
to get someplace sometimes we might ask
you to escort something
across a map while it's being attacked
and so it's a different type of spawning
and it's a different type of units that
are that are in there and it's a simpler
objective
there's a lot of units aaron is talking
about lots of different units lots of
different types they serve different
purposes you do different things to them
it's really going to help a lot of us
find the fun and make sure that
overwatch 2
is a blast of enemies is what we
internally
call objective units and they're
typically units that
don't even attack players the simplest
version would be something like the
breacher
it's two legs with this huge bomb on its
back it was built to do one thing
slowly and methodically march towards
its objective
and then it transforms and the bomb
opens up like a flower
it starts spinning and charging up and
you hear this awesome sound and you know
you have
a little bit of time before it's going
to explode and you have to take it out
we have units like the slicers which you
guys have seen before they're little
we call them the chickens the little
chicken snacks they're right there
really fast
you know we have a guy who works friend
rings right now who flies and drops
these bombs that create these
kind of ever-expanding smoke fields that
you have to escape from because they're
super deadly
so you really get to use your mobility
options to kind of escape that there's
things like
the polar you could be moving through
these
darker alleys and as soon as you hear
that polar spawn
it suddenly becomes like really spooky
and kind of scary
this very tall elegant looking character
that's blindfolded
three orbs that circle around her as her
eyes
and we basically spun those orbs around
her head as a big tell
launch them at the player and then
activate this tractor beam and it's
bringing you
in and bringing you in and then you get
this awesome like anticipation of the
hair
opening up so you know what's about to
happen
one thing we've just recently been
experimenting with is this idea of
elite units we didn't want the elite
units to feel like they're just
oh this guy's got double health and
double damage we want to make sure the
units feel like they have different
behaviors and have different attacks
so for example an omnic grunt normally
he just kind of he fires his gun
he dies pretty simply if you fight elite
crunch
his weapon fires in a burst fire pattern
it's very deadly if you're close
and if you manage to take them out they
don't just die right away they instead
can crawl on the ground towards you and
you
you know you try to back away because
you know if they get to you they can
explode
artillery at blizzcon we're all just
staring at this
and we're like what is what are we going
to do to level this up one of the things
we really felt wasn't coming through
was the damage states we intend for
players to shoot these guns off
but currently it's not reading as
something that can happen in the game
easily
we change the design we change the
animation and we go back and forth and
just continually
iterate we decided hey you know what
we're gonna just delete half of these
damage states so now it's super readable
from an animation standpoint
we decided on spinning barrel version
just did this really nice kickback
the tip of the barrel opens up when it's
about to fire
shifts into place and boom it's
really amazing to be fighting an
artillery unit and you can see the guns
on the side
as you're shooting the guns they're
actually visibly taking damage and then
you can blow them off and it reacts and
kind of stumbles to the side
and really makes you feel like you're
there and it's super fun in
a lot of the stuff we've showed so far
you're fighting a mill sector these are
evil killing machines intent on marching
you down
the way you're going to stop them is by
shooting them and we want to make sure
that feels
responsive and visceral really making
sure that when they take a hit
it feels like their whole body has been
punched almost like hit by a truck
that's what really sells this fantasy
that you're playing these superheroes
one of the cool pieces of technology
that we created was what we call chain
hit reactions
often times you'll find null sector
bunched up marching
maybe a half a dozen units of rest you
expect if you shoot one
they're going to knock them with their
buddies so we made that happen
turns out it's really fun too
one of the things that we showed last
year at blizzcon was the new looks for
our heroes
the theory kind of going in was like you
want to preserve the essence of your
hero
but also kind of show that the hero's
evolved and kind of changed and moved
forward
so we have a lot more new looks so i'm
excited to see how
players and fans react to all of the
ones that we've done so far maybe we'll
share some of those
new looks today which would be cool
we're going to uh mccree's new look for
overwatch 2 as well as farah
and we're really excited to show off
some of our first villains
uh with reaper and widowmaker but first
i wanted to talk a little bit about
technical wear kind of like technical
clothing what that really is is
using you know very techy fabrics as
well as
you know having very intricate but
functional straps designed in a way that
is very aesthetically pleasing with
mccree
we took a couple different approaches
he's got this classic cowboy look that
it's really hard to mess with because if
you try to make him
too sophisticated or too techy it might
not feel right for the character but
as a concept artist you always want to
change things around and try different
shapes and
silhouettes so we did identify as red
sarape as
the main thing for mccree we also tried
a couple different things with increased
cowboy hat
we didn't really want to mess with that
too much because that's a very iconic
part of him
so that's another piece that we that we
kept we tried some
retro cowboy looks that mixed in some
tech here and there
um some that were a little bit more
techy than others some that were a
little bit more
classic cowboy we came a little bit of a
longer beard
and it really gives them a nice kind of
like a more aging look
what's different about pharah than some
of our other heroes is
ferris completely covered in armor we
didn't want to change her silhouette too
much
it was more about experimenting on
different colors so it
felt really appropriate for her to be
the one to hearken back to those
original overwatch colors
of white and blue one of the things that
we wanted to update on farah was her
visor
instead of being completely opaque and
reflective we tried a little bit more of
a transparent approach
and being able to see through it a
little bit now allows us to see
some of her some more of her emotions
reaper was actually the ones i was very
excited to work on because
i could see a lot of potential in how we
can integrate his cloak
and his cowl and his armor and how we
can make all those shapes really sing
within that classic you know reaper
silhouette
we tried a couple takes for the first
pass like completely silver arms
more layers to his jacket reaper's
basket is obviously
pretty sacred to us but the thing you'll
notice immediately is that it's now
completely silver
instead of the bone white he's got this
like almost like deadly edgy silver
that just gives him that classic reaper
look with widowmaker
we started with the idea stage exploring
a breadth of ideas
we tried things like a more insectoid
approach treasure hunter
one of them made her feel like a classic
bond villain so we kind of steered it
back towards one of the more cyberpunk
looking ones almost like a futuristic
femme fatale which is basically what
widowmaker is but she even feels more
upgraded so i'm super glad that we went
down this route we played with different
hairstyles too
widowmaker has the really long ponytail
that's really
key part of her look and really liked
the hairstyle on
one of the designs that was more parade
and it was really interesting
look that also preserves widowmaker's
original silhouette with that long
ponytail
we've been working a lot with our domino
engine
and making our cloth look better now
that we have this cloth tech
we're going gonna be able to make some
really cool unique silhouettes that will
help them stand out from other heroes
we put a lot of time and effort into our
face rig and what i mean by that is
we'll be able to get really close to
these characters and it's gonna feel
really cool
it is absolutely worth the time and
effort to invest in the technology
and that way we can make these
characters do more things that we
haven't really been able to do before
it's been super exciting working on the
new looks for overwatch 2 and it's just
been so inspiring to watch the team
try things that we've never tried before
and i just can't wait to show up more in
the future
overwatch 2 is probably the
largest opportunity we've had since the
inception of the franchise
to really expand what overwatch even
means
to our players in zero hour we saw that
some of the heroes
got back together but we're also seeing
that there seems to be
a second huge omnic uprising
we're gonna learn who's behind that
uprising
why that's happening how globally spread
is it
the story and franchise development
group they were really the torchbearers
of what
the big story is that we were gonna tell
for this game
we have a lot of interaction with them
they're working on
in-game cinematic intros and outros for
every one of our story missions it's
been really great to see this
collaboration grow and develop
the story is just a little more
integrated into our missions than it
ever really has been before
all the available heroes get dialogue
for a given mission
we have npcs we have multiple hero
choices
we have all sorts of events that are
happening that are driving players
to interact with each other or parts of
the
environment or other characters the
world of overwatch
this bright shiny future so how do you
take that bright shiny future and create
conflict in it
how dark can the world of overwatch go
the different
challenges that these characters are
going to have to overcome in overwatch 2
are things that they haven't ever dealt
with before or dealt with on this scale
so what we had to do was literally strip
it down to those bare bones
of where are these characters in their
lives overwatch has been disbanded
and now there's a situation where the
world's in trouble again
and the world needs the heroes again but
they're not allowed to be
doing what they were supposed to be
doing
we started to book these off-site
locations
so we could brainstorm over and over
different versions of what the overwatch
2
story campaign could be and we basically
had these white boards that we were
carting around everywhere the room was
filled with white boards and we would
just write every day
story beats with the characters and who
was doing what and where and oh my gosh
we forgot this character
we had these giant sticky notes and each
one of them would be a mission with a
bunch of notes on it
you know somebody say well what if we
moved rio to the end and they'd
physically grab it off the wall
and stick it on the end and we did this
for a while you know until we all felt
that it was
pretty close to what we wanted then we
could send it to our writers rooms the
writer reforms then had a much
clearer direction of where we wanted
this process to go
ultimately we come up with something
that we think is right
for the game and then we pitch it back
to the game team that we missed
and that allows us to actually back up
and go and make it right and make it
better
because the scale of this story is so
huge it takes place over the whole world
basically
it just requires a constant iteration
constant refinement to make the story as
best as we can make it
from writing we go to storyboards the
storyboards get crafted with the edit
from there it'll go to a previz
department where they'll start to
flesh it out in 3d once we've kind of
figured out our camera work and our
cinematography that'll then go to the
animation department
and then we end up going right into the
game engine
one of our challenges was to figure out
how to integrate this story and this
narrative
with the gameplay so if the intro
cinematic ends with this huge battle
this huge war
when you get into the game it has to
mesh and feel the exact same way and
blend together
we really are also trying to get the
music to be equally as consistent from
in-game cinematics straight through to
the mission adam burgess our lead
composer has been working with the igc
team with the game team
developing themes for all the heroes
all of the locations as the cinematic
director
whatever we're crafting should never
override the gameplay we want to make
sure that
the players experience going from the
cinematic to the gameplay is seamless
and it feels like a completely immersive
experience
the engineers we have to find a way to
actually make that come to fruition
the choreo tool is a tool that allows
people to coordinate different events to
happen at the same time
like in rio if you played our demo one
of the buildings explodes and so
that kind of event needs to happen as
you're running by and you need to have
it timed because if it blows up too
early then you don't see it
it allows story moments in missions that
interact with the environment that
interact with our characters
the new tech the new abilities that we
have now are allowing us to push our
storytelling farther than
we could have previously what's also
really powerful about choreo is that you
know if somebody has an idea
they can mock things up really quickly
we gotta show the widowmaker making this
awesome introduction casey was able to
quickly put
a really rough prototype in corio and
philip would come in and on the fly he's
making quick changes they
play tested something that would
normally take weeks it was done
in like a matter of days
each story mission has its own custom
map built for it and these maps are
absolutely
gigantic india is one of our biggest
maps
and it's a fun map because it has a few
story beats that we've taken from
recent comics and and characters in the
game
we've written a history for each city so
that the cities feel
lived in and i think that informs the
artists so that they know
like what it is that the city has been
through gothenburg was our chance to
show
torbjorn's workshop we created a space
that kind of fits his height so there's
you know step ladders and
scalable tables we designed the space as
if we were a
molten steel is pouring out of walls
it's pretty
epic when you walk into it
toronto is under siege by null sector
when the players arrive here there's a
dynamic snowstorm
so as you make your way through the
level the snow is slowly building up
suddenly by the end the characters are
caught in this gigantic snowstorm and
they must fight their way through
an overwatch
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to the
overwatch 2 developer pvp live stream
i'm your host matt mrx and throughout
the stream i'll be joined by some
awesome content creators and developers
from the overwatch team as we learn
more about overwatch 2's pvp by watching
some of these awesome maps
in action played live it's going to be
an extremely exciting day
aaron mentioned during the developer
update uh everything you see today
is work in progress uh but you know
being able to see some of this stuff you
know day in and day out
uh it's truly awesome really excited for
what the overwatch team has to show for
you guys today so
let's bring on some of my guests uh
throughout the day i'll be joined by the
members of the overwatch dev team
it's associate art director dion rogers
lead hero designer jeff
goodman and game director aaron keller
how you guys feeling today
so much for having us yeah no uh it's
gonna be exciting now we've learned so
much
about the pve aspect of
overwatch too we've learned some stuff
about you know pvp
with uh push roll passives i know new
heroes you saw sojourn at blizzcon line
uh what else has gone into the
development process
for overwatch 2's pvp you're right we've
talked a lot about the story side of of
overwatch 2 and the
the cooperative pve experience that that
we've been working on
but the overwatch team has also been
hard at work
on the pvp side of the game we're making
new features
new heroes new maps some of which we'll
be
playing today and we've also been
looking at the way
pvp has played it's changed over time
on the live game and
we'll talk about a lot of the changes
that that we want to be making and that
we're
currently making um to pvp but
there's one in particular that i want to
highlight right now
um because it's substantial and i think
it has a big impact
on the way the entire team approaches
pvp
on overwatch too and it's it's also
something
that we're all really excited about
overwatch has always been played with
two teams
of six players overwatch two
will be played with two teams of five
players
consisting of two support two dps
and one tank right i was gonna i mean my
next question was gonna be like okay
like is roll queue still a thing so
we still have we still have a breakdown
across the board it's not completely
open so one tank two dps
two supports uh what led you guys down
the road to make this change
there are a lot of reasons for why we
wanted to make this change
as i said earlier overwatch has has
changed
over time um we've we've gone from
having no hero limits at all
in the game before launch you could pick
six winstons if you wanted to for
for your team composition to having a
hero limit
we ended up introducing a roll lock um
over the course of the game and we feel
like this is
the next step in the way that overwatch
ought to be played
if you think about it there is a lot
going on
in an overwatch map it is incredibly
fast paced
and we have always tried to make our
combat
easy to read and very understandable and
even with all of the work that we put
into that
sometimes it's just hard to track what
11 other players
are doing on the battlefield removing
two of those
simplifies everything and it allows
players to understand everything that's
happening
around them and to be able to make
better choices because of it
um this change obviously has a really
big
impact on tanks um and we will get into
some of the changes that that we're
making to tanks and
into some of the other some of the other
roles in a bit
but tanks can be problematic they
they're a dps hero is simple they're
they're shooting
um but but a tank has abilities that
can be noisy um or when stacked with
other tanks can can cause problems for
other teams to
to try to to try to overcome and counter
like and a great example of that
is two main tanks on the field sometimes
that can be
very oppressive to another team um
i think with five with five players out
there
there is a greater chance of of certain
people being able to carry
whether that's the tank on the team or
some of the dps
there's just one less player on the
other team that you need to take care of
and each player now has the opportunity
to have
a larger individual impact on their own
team
and we've we've tried a lot of different
versions of this
internally we've tried 4v4 format
we've tried a three
dps to support one tank format we even
early on
in overwatch development we tried a 7v7
format of the game um and we we always
had
some problems with them and this is the
sort of thing that our lead hero
designer jeff goodman
has really run with and i think he
probably has a little a little more he
can say about it
yeah you forgot about the four dps one
tank one healer we ran one time that was
right
that was literally one test it was like
one play test and we
would never do anything in the middle of
that but never to be never to be spoken
about again
yeah yeah jeff i assume that uh
obviously
you know changes to the tank roll but i
assume there will be kind of like
holistic changes overall right i think
just changing the tanks you probably
need to rework some of the other stuff
that goes on
oh yeah i mean this is a kind of change
so
uh that it impacts like the huge part of
the game obviously and
um that's the thing about sort of hero
design and hero balance is like
it's sort of easy and sometimes it's
easy but
it's certainly easier to make sort of a
single hero change and you know
maybe even like your rework like you've
done in the past but to change something
so fundamental as
you know there's only one tank allowed
really kind of cascades into a lot of
different questions and and
you know uh problems that demand answers
so i mean the obvious thing comes up in
people's mind probably immediately when
we say this
is how does roadhog work in a world
where you could pick reinhardt instead
like how do they how is that as an
equivalent pick
so that's sort of our first question
when we were doing it too like we liked
this 5v5 thing it was super fun we
playtested it
that has a lot of promise but okay we
have to solve a lot of problems if we go
this way
um so that's sort of why it sort of has
led to this larger
set of changes and there's a lot of
other things we'll talk about as well um
but it definitely um cascades you know
for example
healing just healing you can kind of
focus on one tank now the tanks are even
beefier than
they are in live the individual tanks
because this is one of them so now we're
thinking well is it
is it too good to just play like two
main healers and dump healing in your
tank and is it too hard to kill now and
maybe healing is too good now and you
know it's just it's it's
but this is the time to do it this is
what we wanted to do with our watch too
is look at
core things like this and make sure that
where we want them to be
and doing a lot of fun yeah i was going
to say like uh
you know i'm not a designer but i think
that like this is the first real
opportunity you guys have had to
reset like you couldn't just do this on
the live game right i
i think that's kind of like what i what
i assume right is that this is like a
holistic look
at the game overall and like changes
that you couldn't do on live because
they're just so massive
exactly and like i said there's other
changes that go along with this as well
um that are also equally impactful so
it's sort of like
we just like shook the ground underneath
the game like really heavily and like
all the pieces are
kind of and disarray a little bit so
some of the heroes won't even be
playable really by our
our playtesters here um because they're
either heroes we're already kind of
looking at heavily we plan on looking at
heavily so it's kind of not worth
showing them in this context or ones
that we haven't addressed yet things
like that so
um that just sort of gives you context
of like how big this kind of change is
well i i want to get right into the game
uh i want to see it live i'm sure the
fans want to see it live after getting
all this like
info uh the first map we're gonna be
showing you guys today
is new york city uh dion what kind of
map is this
um new york is a hybrid map so a brand
new hybrid map for overwatch too
and there's a fun new payload for
players to battle over
the world building team had a great time
just
creating this overwatch depiction of new
york it's tons of
neat details and fun easter eggs for the
players to find so
i i think it should be fun to take a
look at this
yeah no i when you guys showed this at a
blizzcon line i was so excited obviously
from new york
uh myself would love to see the midtown
tunnel go over
some of the adjustments that you guys
have made to it here
in in overwatch too uh just
yeah just a beautiful map i have to
imagine this is one of the locales that
you guys have been dying to do for a
while
we've been wanting to there's a lot of
people on the team from new york or who
have spent some part of their life there
so
it's always been on the list and
overwatch 2 felt like the right time to
do it
and uh no short of easter eggs i would
say
no i know on some of these maps so far
uh please
you know get get some love at the
beginning but uh yeah this will be our
first real look
at 5e5 uh i've had the
opportunity to like kind of watch some
games like as they've kind of tested it
out
uh it it's it still keeps that overwatch
you know fast-paced
feel but it it doesn't have like you
know kind of the the clumped up chaos
that you sometimes see of live i think
it kind of speaks to really what you
were pointing to jeff
is that when you have you know that one
less tank in the equation you can
actually make the tanks more aggressive
and more offensive
uh but it's also just kind of easier for
the viewer and
just people at home to track yeah
absolutely
and um you'll see probably a lot of play
here
one of the biggest things you'll notice
because there's less protection
from coming from tank players just to
directly block bullets for the team
typically you will find a lot more
player on the map corners
map angles uh often going for cheeky
flanks and stuff
dion loves this to use the environment a
lot more it's a bit more tactical
yeah exactly which is great um
so it kind of you know that was one of
the first things that came out of our
original play testing and we were just
like this is
a really good direction i mean like i
mentioned there's like
you know as a designer you sort of have
to look past the immediate like problems
in front of you and like okay we could
fix those
like i think we can address the you know
some of the like tank imbalances and
healing issues and all kinds of
stuff but at the heart of this which is
really cool and so that's that's really
what we've been focusing on and working
through these problems
i think something that's really
interesting about that too is that
the gameplay is is more fluid than it
was before
a lot of times in overwatch you get
these these really hard battle lines
that get drawn between the two teams and
there's just less damage incoming
and so you're able to kind of move
around a little bit more
and you'll see it here a lot of times
the chokes aren't as hard of a space to
to get through there's still a choke in
the map and you still have to work at it
but there can be a lot more like pushing
through and and pulling back
on the choke and it's something that i'm
like personally personally really
excited about
i was gonna say uh how has uh the 5v5
move affected
map design i feel like it kind of has to
have a huge impact on
you know what you guys are able to do
create different those speaking about
like players being able to take more
control of the game right
no creating more flanking routes you
know more opportunity for you know the
the ash to go to the side get a pick and
open things up for a team
yeah there's a lot more opportunity um
for for players to do that
but at the same time when when you go
for a flank
you're not leaving five players behind
you're leaving four players behind and
so
you you kind of have to be weighing some
of these decisions in your head the game
is just as strategic
as it was before um if not more so
because of the the
individual ability for players to have
such a large impact
on the match i think for map design
we've always been um really careful to
make spaces that feel good
just for one hero and sometimes
we might favor particular heroes in
different areas
but because of that because we're able
to to make a space that kind of feels
good for reaper or a space that feels
good for pharah
i think that we'll still be able to play
5v5
on all of the original catalog of
overwatch maps as well
right that is a awesome payload dion by
the way
and you know we've always in in the
artwork of the maps we've always placed
what we consider
cover objects it just feels now with the
5v5
players will take advantage of that more
you know even the previous maps we've
we planned cover objects to help protect
players
now with 5v5 they're even more effective
these artistic choices
it's such a great point too because we
have started placing a little bit more
cover in our maps
and if you go back to some of the old
maps like if you look at king's row
that middle section that street section
of king's row
there's one piece of cover in that
entire
section it's just corners of buildings
is what you're using
yeah no that's a that's a great point i
think you can kind of see it here even
with i know stuff like that i know the
taxis here in the
streets you know you have the little
kind of windows the pillar to hide
behind in the middle
uh there's a route through the subway
there's so many different kind of angles
uh you can take uh something we saw
at blizzcon line was the uh two fire
strike charge
uh cancel reinhardt uh i noticed
something before
jeff when we were on with winston uh my
winston
uh not able to shoot at range can you
can you explain that to us a little bit
sorry i was wondering if people picked
up on that so we were first watching
winston there
um this is an example of you know some
of the tank changes we're talking about
um in regards to 5v5 but also a larger
change we're talking about making tanks
uh a lot more aggressive be able to um
be a little more hybridy on the damage
side and less just raw protection
um so on winston's side um he's holding
right now unfortunately you can't see it
but
he can't do it but his uh his alternate
fire there which he's doing right now
there it is
you can charge up like a condensed blast
of lightning from his gun and fire it
off as a single
sort of like a blast attack at longer
range
um and so he actually the charge up is
kind of interesting with it for him
because you could do it while you're
leaping
and so there's like theoretically more
burst combos you can do where you're
jumping on top of somebody charging up
in the air
and first you know release it right
before you land on them and then you get
the stomp damage too and
you can shock them or do a quick melee
combo there's a lot more interesting
things on top of the fact that
you know with some players know a lot of
times you're you're you know you shock
somebody they're getting away
you think you can finish them and they
just like you know fair abuse away or
somebody just
gets away you get that extra you know
alternate fire shot to try to
take him out on the way and it's
actually interesting playing against him
now because you now are cognizant of
that so sometimes you're leaving a
little earlier like well i'm gonna get
blasted probably if i just like run away
so
i have to be able to survive that yeah i
think that's one of the decisions all
winston players face it's like okay i've
jumped on this player i've gotten
them weak i can either now get out of my
bubble and try to
finish them off or just kind of hope a
teammate does but now giving him
i think it kind of goes back to more
like that player you know agency that
you were talking about being able to
kind of take over the game
being able to finish it off this
nanoboosted rhine uh
this will never get old you know just to
see in there
and reinhardt nano boosted just swinging
i'm sure it makes the fans out there
happy that i know that was a
a dragon blade a guilty genji he was
able to take out his uh
it's kind of the bane of existence of a
lot of people
uh but this looks like i guess the
second checkpoint right so
this will unlock the interior of grand
central station
oh this is awesome so it goes in so the
payload kind of goes in station and
uh kind of curves around i guess
you can see the payload is driven by
an omnic who is a little easter egg to
our production direct
uh production director on the team our
executive producer
he got a name yes choco
he's gonna be a fan favorite oh he's
even got it on the back i realized i
thought it was like
i thought it was like an unofficial name
like oh yeah no
he's he's got the suit our executive
producer said he's
he's helped us out a lot and it was only
fitting
he has a he's lived in new york as well
yeah he helped out a lot on this map
and we have um countless debates about
the right type of pizza
with him as well yes yeah i mean the
new york style pizza is the dominant
pizza uh i believe it's the water but
uh that is probably for a different
stream yeah you really want to get into
this my
my thoughts on the the water in new york
creating the better pizza dough
uh i you you also notice uh at least i
noticed
the new sounds especially when like ash
shoots
uh that is something that uh no it was
discussed at blizzcon line
but i think it's different to kind of
see it in action and also
to see all of the other players at the
same time with those audio changes
it just makes the game feel even more
realistic
yeah the sounds can get really punchy
and it just
feels good to hold the trigger down with
these different heroes
but you also get more information from
it so
we've spent a lot of time not just
developing what these sounds are but
how they play in different environments
so we've kind of upgraded the entire
sound system across the game so
let's say when um that ash is in a side
room
firing from that room you really kind of
understand where they're at and what
type of environment that they're in
better than you did before and then you
can kind of take that information and
make different decisions
or or additional decisions because of it
all right so we got a map complete from
the offense here
not bad not bad at their first go the
the players are so competitive i have to
say this to the stream that
you're like yeah this is fun like
everybody have a great time and then
everyone's like put your sr in the chat
we're gonna make balance
teams like who's playing what it's uh
it's just i feel like it's just the
nature of overwatch right like it
it always starts off yeah let's play for
fun and then you know you you lose a
game you're like all right
like everybody pick it up like let's
let's change things
it's like that meme when you like you're
playing relaxing your chair and then you
lose and you lean forward get a little
more
get the yeah it's those nights of ranked
where you lose like two and you're like
you win one and then you're like all
right play to lose and then you
you lose a few more and then the next
thing you know you wake up you're like
why'd i do that like 500 sr down the
drain
that's uh so this will be an opportunity
to see like roadhog has a
a solo tank uh coming in for the
offensive side here
uh i feel like he's just gonna be even
on uh live right he just takes up so
much
space jeff like and and he takes up
space not with a shield but like just
his body as i say that
we we have a zarya swah but uh talk to
me a little bit about like the thoughts
on you know how how like the road hogs
of the world divas uh even
zarya i know there's some interesting
stuff with zarya as a solo tank
yeah so like i said before a lot of this
is the work of progress we're still um
yeah
sort of addressing here by hero um but
like because
once we started going to one tank it was
sort of the big question was like
kind of what direction are we pushing
tanks now we going
we're trying to make roadhog you know a
lot more static
defensively and have you know big
barriers or something to protect a team
or do we want more the opposite would
like to take the reinhardts and the
wrists and sigmas and actually
get give them some more aggression and
be a little more like uh
robot diva um and so we definitely opted
for that ladder rat after playing
because it's like
not only is it just more fun to have
that kind of extra speed and aggression
but you know a lot of what people uh
had a lot of comments on them in the
past when the metas get too full of
barriers and shields and honestly even
sometimes when there's just
you know the one erisa blocking you with
just
the chain shields and it's just like you
know people had comments like i
feel like i'm shooting shields all the
time which so like we were definitely
hearing all that and you could see
some of the balance changes we've made
in the past live game i'm trying to
address this but
um once we got into this situation we're
like oh
this is sort of an opportunity actually
here to reduce a lot of these effects
and you know we still want them to be
there and present and be important you
can still block huge abilities
um they still have a decent amount of
health but you know less than they had
before
um but then in response to that we get
to you can see reiner here
he get well you can hit the ball right
there you can cancel it but you can
cancel your charge
and you can get two two fire strikes um
so he's the canceling charge is one of
those like sneaky things that seems like
to some people might be kind of a minor
change but it almost like completely
changes how he plays a lot of ways it's
actually really fun because you can
uh it has a really fast recovery when
you cancel so you can like charge up to
a group and then cancel and immediately
ult and just like knock everyone down
so the fact that you can even do that
it's its own now like
sort of mini game that people play where
you can kind of bluff with it if people
know you have your old you think you
have your old
you can charge right at them and they're
trying not to get stunned like they
don't want to fight you necessarily like
normally because they don't want to get
they're shattered so sometimes you can
like bluff people and are running for
cover you didn't even have it or you'd
save it or something so
and it also just allows him to you know
get in there and be more aggressive
without
sacrificing his health part yeah just
sounds like another uh
change almost like how you kind of
mention like stuff like that winston
combo kind of
you know as you're as you're playing and
testing and seeing all these different
things like
yeah where the winston combo you can you
know load up that secondary fire come
like get the jump damage land on
somebody take them out like
now you kind of have like this like
little metagame with like reinhardt play
right where you know that you kind of
have like this another layer of
cancelling the charge you know being
able to
i remember there was one clip i think
from uh blizzcon line and just like a
trailer where
he he charges towards the team cancels
and then shatters them all
uh getting able to make plays like that
just seems
so sick he's also got the ability to
um to control his charge more so you can
actually
turn around corners more oh yeah um so
the the charge while you cancel it's
also more aggressive and it's more
versatile
um i think something else that's really
interesting um
if you look at the if people have
noticed what's happening with zarya
is she has two charges to her bubble now
that sure charges is the trick it's
actually what we play tested in uh
for the april fool's patch so as people
probably noted like
you know some of those changes were a
lot of them were just silly kind of fun
like permanently flying sigma
but you know there were some changes he
threw in there it's like let's see how
people react to this i'm curious what
people think like maybe this thing we
can try
uh zarya bubbles is one of those things
so
aaron you know it's something we just
reached
oh yeah it took me a while to get used
to the new changes but
once once i really dug in and and
settled with these changes i realized
it's how i i always wanted to play
reinhardt this way basically
you know the charge and
so we were joking about that the other
day where uh uh even uh
i'm like yeah like the the cancelling
the charge just feels so right that
yeah but you're so like trained to kind
of how it is like where you're just
charging in the walls
that i was like wait i was like i don't
have to do this anymore no like i can
just i can just go
like uh it's it's such like a great
quality of life change
yeah something else i think that's
really interesting here is this like
this fight's been going on for a while
neither tank has fallen and the support
had been doing such a good job
at keeping the tanks up because there's
there's only one of them that
that they have to actually focus on um
and the fights
feel really really good being the
tank player now like the amount of times
you get into this situation
where it feels hopeless you're low on
health
um there's a bunch of the enemy players
focusing on you
and you're able to still come out of it
um it feels so incredibly good and you
feel really powerful
yeah it's uh it i think that that has to
be something that you guys have kind of
gotten in feedback that from a support
point of view you're able to dump
resources
into just one tank and that also
probably frees you up to do
a little bit of other stuff right where
the batiste can do a little bit more
damage
you know zen you can kind of orb the
tank and then focus on the damage
that uh probably has to be way easier on
supports now
for sure yeah we we got a lot of
feedback from support players
it it's a lot easier to focus and a lot
of times you almost have this like
uh communication between the two support
players and you know you have like
mercy's like i'm just gonna be you know
on tank duty and just be on tank
basically the whole time
and you have like a lucio or something
like that to spot heal
everybody else and speed everybody up
but there's other strats like sometimes
we've seen
people go too big you know main healers
essentially and try to just
focus so hard on the tank that even with
like disc or bottom it's just hard to
kill them
um so that's going to be just in strat
too so i don't even sure like what the
meta is entirely at especially because
we're changing things all the time
because it's pretty hard for them to
settle but yeah
it's a lot of fun uh this zen ui
is uh new oh yeah uh it actually looks
really
cool uh is this is something obviously
that's uh incredibly new i think i'll
live like that it's kind of displayed on
the right
yeah go ahead sorry jeff
i was saying we're generally looking at
anywhere we can improve
uh hero specific ui stuff like this and
we felt like this could use
you know a big update and be a lot more
readable
yeah i think one of the things i'm most
excited about with the healer ui
is um it's not just on zen but it's on
mercy also
you see the portrait of the of the
player that you're healing
um and so it's just a lot easier to kind
of figure out who you've got
um instead of just using something like
a name plate you know
i mean yeah and it's not off to the side
right it's like center screen so you're
able to still kind of focus down the
middle
yeah and you can see his discord is down
there as well so you have like harmony
and discord orbs are kind of both
um shown on each side of the of the alt
at the bottom of the screen
we have an overtime here i i can imagine
the calms are uh
everybody's starting to get pretty
sweaty now
we get towards the end of the map uh
so this has really been i gotta say for
you guys probably uh
this is probably awesome to see like the
game actually being it's one thing i
think to play but now to like observe
and be able to watch and
obviously you know the people you guys
work with every day this has to be
pretty awesome
yeah it definitely is we've been playing
it in this state for a long time too and
it's always
it's always so tough to to
play a game a certain way at work and
then go home and it
it operates in a totally different way
and you're playing with people online
and you can't help but think like if
only you knew
what i was playing you know every day um
and so it's just it feels really good to
to have that out in front of
in front of our community so they can
kind of see what we've been doing
they actually talk about small changes
in here too like i'm curious if
people picked up on after one game um
like one example of a small change that
uh actually we end up removing but it's
in this build right now
is um because we've had it for a while
now but we just had to reduce discussion
maybe we want to pull it again is uh
we've actually slowed the movement
acceleration rate of
everybody in the game just very slightly
and the reason for that was to try to
create
um a little more uh
sort of prediction element to shooting
an enemy as opposed to like you can kind
of
you know ada d spam a lot of times or
just like turn directions so fast that
it was really hard to lead a shot or
you know sometimes it felt like you're
you're
guessing a little bit on which direction
they're gonna go so we tried to like
just notch it down just a little bit so
you can't really feel it as much in in
first person but
um it's kind of one of those subtle
things but uh after sitting with her for
a while even just like i think it was
like last week or earlier this week
we started bringing up a thread again
like do we want to keep this actually
this has been around for a while is
everyone's so happy with this so
that's just very controversial like
among the design teams there's a lot of
back and forth
on this one so but i think what it it
whether or not
we keep a change like that in the game i
think what it speaks to
is the the amount of systems and how
deep we're looking at like the entire
experience of pvp in the game
yeah seems like no uh no stone on pvp is
being left like i know
untouched right where you're able to
kind of look under kind of every rock
you know see
see what you guys want to do uh i want
to bring somebody in from the community
uh real quick i can uh welcome in
stylosa
uh dude what do you think uh first looks
what'd you have what'd you think man
uh i'll be honest i was a little bit
skeptical when i first heard about 5v5
um
you know ripped to the off tanks kind of
thing but um i don't know
based off watching that uh first map
there on new york
i don't know it looks quite spicy this
does could be quite good
yeah no uh uh i i'm really excited like
as somebody who
uh i i will wait in the dps queue uh you
know
as as long as i got away you know and
but now like seeing the tanks and seeing
how aggressive you can play and you know
push the pace
uh i'm i'm excited uh to to be able to
kind of now
dive into the tank roll and also when
i'm support you know uh to throw a few
heels on my tank and start pumping out
some damage you know
oh i mean while super buff tanks you're
just gonna go in right
this is uh yeah it's always better well
when you're playing reinhardt right you
don't want to charge in most of the time
but now it's like yeah just going
yeah now yeah now now i'm uh
i'm going full throttle i'm charging
back in we can bring up we can bring
aaron and jeff back in uh as our our
next map is going to be a game mode that
we saw
at blizzcon line uh blizzcon in 2018
it seems like uh forever ago is a push
uh how has the game mode changed since
we last saw
it um we haven't made a lot of
changes to the mode itself at least as
far as like the big
rules go for it but we've continued
developing for it so
we we have more than one push map
in development and i think we have more
than one that we'll even be looking at
today so we're really committed to the
mode
and we have a lot of fun playing this
thing
i think the the interesting thing about
push to me
is that um from the outside it sort of
looks like it's a riff
on payload um but there's something
about
having the this robot move back and
forth
in the map that makes this very special
i almost think of push um more as a
moving control point or or
or a match of control more than
a a match of payload um
and you'll kind of see it the the the
mode can be
really flanky um so there's a lot of
other heroes in here that i think you
can get play
and push and a lot of that has to do
with just the
the bi-directional nature of that robot
in the map and also
because of how quickly it moves yeah now
if you've never seen push before
uh there's a robot in the middle both
teams will come out and kind of fight
for it and then once you get control you
can start pushing your barricade
towards the opponent's spawn it's the
name push guys
uh stylosa you played it yeah i know
apple's con
how did you find it then i mean it seems
like such a long time ago when i played
this at blizzcon
uh yeah it was pretty hectic i mean i i
will say though the
teams were horrendously unbalanced at
blizzcon and uh
i mean i think i had like siegel xqc uh
fran
and me were playing against random
people
it was a massacre i'll be honest i was
just afk
it didn't really matter but uh yeah it
was um
i can't wait to see it i just hey any
overwatch 2 news give it me i'll consume
that stuff
i've just given me how do you guys think
it feels now
uh in 5e5 because the last time we saw
push at blizzcon
the pvp was six on six does it play any
different you guys feel especially on
toronto
a little bit um so push has always been
maybe our most hectic mode or our most
dynamic
game mode um and part of the reason for
that is the way these maps are designed
is we have a very um sort of like
wavy path that the robot travels on so
the objective is kind of always moving
back and forth
and then we have a lot of very direct
routes across the map that the players
can take and because of that
it allows players to take a lot of
shortcuts circle around the enemy team
and it creates a lot of these flanking
opportunities um
with five players there's just one less
person you kind of have to kind of keep
in the in in your minds focus and and
kind of like worrying about where
they're going to show up at any time
and so it's settled down a little bit i
still think it has
that dynamic dynamic nature that we've
always loved about push it's just a
little bit easier
to to kind of understand fast-paced
i think that's uh yeah that's kind of
the way i would put it like you have
uh a lot of the buildings you can go
through different types of routes you
can take
uh i'm i'm excited let's jump into map
number two this will be uh
toronto this will be push uh this is the
map that we actually saw uh back at
blizzcon uh we all had a chance to play
uh it was awesome then i'm excited to
see some of the like the
the flanking characters you can kind of
get like an overhead view of the map now
and see
you know your your tracers your genji's
on this type of map reaper is the one to
watch for i think
has reaper been tearing it up
[Laughter]
so is this map the same as it was back
at blizzcon
um or has been any alterations to it um
it's
it's virtually the same um yeah with
when we had the map at blizzcon it's um
it was definitely a work in progress and
it's still a work in progress now but
we've had the opportunity to add
additional polish and and art
um resources into the map since then
all the maps just look so good uh i i
know i see stylos's face when we do the
fly through and he's just like
smiling and he's just like so giddy like
oh it's like
so it's so fun where i feel like uh i
feel like
push is going to add a different type of
element to the game
that like escort in in a hybrid like you
mentioned like the payload oriented maps
and i think push kind of plays like that
a little bit
but there's so much more movement i feel
like than both of those
and just you take so many different
fights all over the map
uh and i also love the fact that you
just can't really tie
on this map i think uh one of the things
uh like about assault is that you can
you know you have like these like long
like battles and then it's a draw and
you're just like i wanted to
i mean i mean maybe even be okay taking
a loss there you know but like
uh this you definitely get a winner yeah
definitely and
i really like game modes where the
actual objective and the mechanics help
pace out the the speed of gameplay
and it was really really hard for us to
do that with 2cp
you can have incredibly long matches in
2cp
and sometimes like a really quick
blowouts
um and it just came down to what the two
teams were doing and
the game mode itself wasn't really doing
anything to enforce that the way it
might in control or in payload
uh and so with push we have more of that
to where the game mode is actually
is actually helping to control the
length of the match
um and and the the pace of the match
yes uh you see on the clock it's a eight
minute
uh clock right now so yeah it is uh it
is pretty
fast i think it's definitely intended
with you know some of these fighters are
behind as uh
it's a poor lumpy gets taken out right
off right right right off the rim lumpy
was going on one of those flanks didn't
turn out uh
it didn't turn out so well so does the
uh the bottom lock right away
um it takes about 30 seconds for it to
unlock and the reason we do that
is we don't want a team to think that
there's a certain amount of
of pressure to have all this pressure to
get to it as quickly as possible we want
you to be able to be
strategic with the way that you um
approach the bot in the middle of the
map and
it's it's very similar to the way that
control works so we can see the the
robot he's got a name right
yeah his name is two
oh that's good so we see uh
some genji play in action is yeah you
see like all the buildings you can kind
of come from players
you know up above to the side i think
you can definitely see that like
you know fast paced it it looks uh
way more like you can as a dps player
just kind of go off to the side make a
play
try and make it you see here they're
going right for the supports yep
yeah and and the map there's still a
main path in push yeah
it's really important for us to have
that in all of our in all of our map
types
um but there are a lot of ways to get
around that and to get through it and
that's what creates a lot of these
opportunities
he's going for the remit kill can't
blame him
[Laughter]
yeah yeah i'm here i'm i'm fixated on
the gameplay i think uh yeah i mean this
looks this looks really deathmatchy this
does like
we're just you know they're just going
in there and a good old brawl and then
obviously that as the mech or the the
point is moving through the map
it's changing up every single time and
it's just
it to be honest it looks fairly similar
to what i played back at blizzcon all
those years ago
just with yeah that's tank it's just
yeah yeah but it's just more space i
think to operate yeah yeah uh
like i'm i'm somebody who i
play a ton of dps like and i'm excited
that maybe not everybody will run around
in like a death ball and i'll be able to
kind of like play tracer and go off to
the side
and make a play i noticed too uh the
green health
over lucio here oh yeah what is that on
a ui now
actually forgot about that so many
changes
i was like i was like uh sound barrier
doesn't give green health when i do it
right so that's something um where we're
changing up i
you know like everything is working
progress it's possible to change
although we're pretty happy with it
right now
um this is a change to uh what we kind
of call overhealth this is a larger
system which is
you know on overwatch one you can have
over armor and over shields depending on
who's giving it to you much like you can
have normal health and shields
and armor um so you know once we started
getting into
trying to create clarity and make sure
the game is very readable
in all these senses you know like i
mentioned with the zenyatta's ui and
everything
um that came up too is like you know
it's possible to get
especially you get into like pve talents
and stuff like that your health bar can
get really colorful really fast like
you could have you know health and then
armor and then shields and then over
health armor and shields you could
literally have
six segmented colored health and it was
like i can't even
understand what i'm looking at right now
this is like so insane
so it's we ended up um condensing all of
the over
over health uh concepts into just one
concept now and so you know it was kind
of kind of interesting other than
summer's emp over shields was more of
thematic thing than anything
because it doesn't it didn't regen like
normal shields because it's over health
doesn't have a
regeneration value so it was like it was
kind of nonsense anyway honestly
so now we can have everything getting us
into green health and it's very
understandable that
you know you see somebody with green and
you can see like okay that's not
you know that's over healthy it's either
going to drain or if i shoot through it
it can't be heated
and stuff like that so um kind of helps
uh clarify all that
poor tea is going to work out going back
and forth but uh
i noticed before there was like a circle
so is there like kind of uh
capture points like progress does that
change the respawns at all how does that
work on push
yeah it does so the robot starts in the
middle of the map and
it pushes those um like those red
barricades in front of it and you can
use those to
kind of like in world see what your high
water mark is
and if if the robot is able to push it
to the checkpoint
it will unlock a forward spawn room for
the the team that was able to do you can
kind of see it just off to the left here
behind reinhardt
um so if the attacking team can push it
over there they'll unlock that spawn
point
and it gives them a big advantage in
order to kind of push through the rest
of the map
and then i assume when they're uh when
two starts moving the other direction i
guess it'd be
uh decides to start moving the other
direction uh
they would lose that forward spawn right
yeah
yep there is an additional detail there
it's two has to be pushed back to the
middle of the map
before you lose your forward spawn room
and we actually started it
the way um that you described it but a
lot of times the robot
could cross this one checkpoint and it
got like really chaotic and you'd have
no idea where you were gonna spawn so we
we kind of gave you a grace period in
there
or made it a little bit stickier by by
forcing him to return to the middle
yeah that's a good call i can imagine if
that was the case now yeah you would
have like if i spawned this one second i
would spawn close and then like stylosis
spawns the next second he's far away yep
and i i mean that happens in overwatch
you know um but it was just
it was way too blatant this way bubble
zarya is sick
she is incredible it's actually a pretty
recent
thing we put checked it in but it's
pretty good it's a damaged ram thought
when she's charged
by more so yeah yeah so
you have the same bubbles you have
before but yeah they're both using
shared charges so yeah
we found that because this increased
flexibility and how you use it she tends
to be a higher charge
more often uh i mean this is a good
example i guess
but so it's actually even a lot of play
tests
i could find myself like you know
sending a message to people what was
your average
energy would you say you're kind of
tearing it up
but it looks so fun though i mean as
somebody who loves to play
zarya like uh i also can imagine the
people that i would play with on zarya
would just
automatically double bubble themselves
everybody
else yeah let's just run in a double
bubble ourselves but then you start to
think like
actually if i save two and you know
genji pulls out his blade on my team
i think i fight double shield him and
you know i save that up
that's gonna be kind of ridiculous so
yeah i didn't even think of that like uh
yeah not just applying the two
bubbles to yourself but you could
because they shared the charge you could
theoretically like bubble a genji blade
and then bubble him again right
yeah oh yeah it works really well
so so many different ways yeah so this
is like
as it just just kind of recently put in
um coming off the back of the
um april 1st stuff and seeing how we
feel about it and
it's um been pretty interesting i i i'm
certainly concerned about it in some
cases but it also this is some really
awesome play so
i'm kind of letting it rock for a while
and see see how it feels
work in progress but yeah i i like the
progress on that one
so so uh ot how does the rule here work
i guess they have to push all the way to
the end or do they just have to
beat the time of the blue team they just
need to beat the time of the blue team
so
the the win condition for push is
whoever
has pushed it the furthest by the end of
time wins
or if you have it or if you're able to
push it all the way to the end of the
map you'll win instantly
so now they're unlocking their forward
spawn room right here oh the
the tragedy strikes for the blue team
yeah they need to stay near the robot uh
i believe to keep pushing
yeah yep yeah right let's see so you can
have
you know the the the good old blunder
where everybody walks off the objective
and two just looks sad
i don't know what you're talking about
yeah i imagine these games go right down
to the wire
uh definitely hectic there towards the
end this is this is going to be quite
good for overwatch league i'd imagine
this is um i enjoyed that i really
enjoyed watching that
yeah i think uh stylist i think your
point like uh
yeah when you think about like you know
5v5 or 606 you're like oh well
like does it still have that like you
know big like
energy like that fast paced like kind of
and you see it there i think especially
on push i think it's why it's such like
a great representative of the
the game uh is that yeah you still have
these fast-paced fights you know you're
you're able to you know make plays all
over the map it sort of ramps up right
as the match goes on it's more and more
and more intense and
you have a big sort of crescendo towards
the end that's really nice i really like
it it's got it's got that overwatch
music where it kind of adds to the
the suspense of it all yeah and push
this happens in push a lot it goes to
overtime
more often than it does and it was a
decision that we made
when we were developing the mode where
we had to decide what was more important
for push was it
for one team to be able to get the robot
all the way to the end of the map
or is it more important for the robot to
be moving back and forth
in the map um because it's it's really
hard to get both of those and so
we think that this this mode plays
better to have it moving back and forth
more often and so
the the mode mechanics and the map
design is all kind of tailored to have
that
and it can and it makes it like really
really exciting
yeah it's just the fast moving fast flow
of combat right i think uh the kind of
jeff like in your wheelhouse right like
for just hero design and being able to
kind of come up with these creative
different things that you know
like we saw zarya there on push like
it's not a hero that you would kind of
think for like an
aggressive type of game mode like that
but she was like she looked don't kill
him all the time and she was
crazy she's really scary in this form
for sure and
you know i think that's kind of what
we're thinking for a lot of these
uh you know sort of off-tanky kind of
characters before you know roadhog
and diva and we saw diva that played as
well and diva's got a lot of changes too
so
i think it's worth noting that we're not
like taking every tank and just
making them super aggro in some cases
we're pushing some of the more agro
tanks and making them a little tankier
so
i mean a lot of cases they have a lot
more health as people notice but um
diva has a lot more sort of matrix juice
in the can
so she can use it a lot more so that's
an example of where we didn't just like
give her more missiles or something like
that and let her go kill everybody it's
like she can actually protect her team a
little more so she slides a little bit
closer towards
you know the the defensive route there's
probably players out there who want
those missiles but
i'm not happy i'm happy i'm happy i'm
happy that it's not happening but uh
final thoughts man uh excited to have
you on what do you think yeah no i'm i'm
i am very impressed with that much more
impressed than i thought it would be
um it's been so long since i've seen
push in action
um and it yeah it definitely looks
better 5v5
like yeah i don't know that that's i
want to see more i want to see more of
it
you know i feel hard done but i just get
in one game
silos is not going to leave the car
playing to stake down and just hang out
but uh guys we're gonna go for a quick
break
don't go anywhere when we come back
super's gonna join the show
give his thoughts on some of the things
he's seen go over some of the stuff
that's going on with the tanks
you don't want to miss it stay tuned
from above
my power
i'm going for that
[Music]
oh
translocated
i can do this with my eyes closed
forward barrier
dammit
welcome back ladies and gentlemen to the
overwatch 2 pvp developer livestream i'm
mitch leslie and
already we've seen a ton of what is in
the works
for overwatch 2 pvp there's a lot to
take in
obviously with new maps new game types
and changes of course to some of the
core mechanics of the game so
we're gonna rehash a couple of things of
course over the next few maps but we
want to drill down
on a couple of things we've already
talked about so far to help me do that
now we'll be joining
our overwatch league superstar matthew
super delicia of course is uh
everybody's favorite neighborhood main
tank
how you doing super obviously uh big
news today i'd love to get some of your
initial thoughts on it
yeah thanks for having me first of all
um i mean the tank changes that's
definitely the one that you know kind of
stuck out to me
uh the fact that you know only one tank
is i'm a tank player
and you know my experience so tank you
know it goes up it goes down sometimes
you get bullied
uh as as a tank with two um so i'm
curious to see how
that's going to progress and change to
make it so that it's a lot easier for
one tank to be
uh you know work properly and not have
as many struggles
yeah i mean this is something i think
you watch in any sort of tank players
stream right now you can sort of see
plenty of the apps and also some of the
downs here obviously we saw
you know maybe some more power being
shifted in the direction of the tanks
right you know we saw reinhardt with the
double fire strikes he's got some more
of that charge control and the winston
changes what was your thoughts
uh when you first saw the fact that
winston now has a bit of longer range uh
equipment to bring into the fight yeah i
thought that was uh
a little bit interesting i also like
that they
grabbed the zarya from the experimental
um
i mean at least in my ch when i played
the experimental i thought that the cool
nail needed to be shorter on that
um but i i like that in general they're
trying to give more power if it's going
to be just one tank
uh because i feel like otherwise a lot
of tanks like you know
zarya and diva uh they would kind of
struggle because but
they're the way they're designed right
now i feel like they weren't really
um you know made to be played solo if
that makes sense
um but now i feel like if they if they
do the proper changes
i think it could actually be pretty good
uh absolutely you saw there as well a
couple of the changes we mentioned
winston's
maze we haven't really talked about it
it's definitely part of a wider
conversation that we can sort of tap
into
uh in a moment and of course uh we'll be
rejoined in in just a moment by some
members of our development team as well
to maybe add some context and field
some more of these questions here we
already heard a little bit about
uh diva and uh sort of the way that she
was sort of tweaked so i want to take
this opportunity to bring back in
jeff goodman of course the lead hero
designer on overwatch 2
and dion rogers our associate art
director guys thank you so much
for joining us here of course now you
have a bonafide main tank play at the
professional level in the room here and
uh super of course a chance to share
some of your thoughts but
gentlemen overall it definitely feels
like the role of the tank
changes vastly now in this light in this
landscape not only is it just one tank
but maybe some of the roles
or things you're expected to do in the
game may have shifted
yeah i think absolutely i i mean it's
sort of like
it you know definitely in the past it's
somewhat true as well that you're
definitely leading your team but i think
now
you're doing kind of by yourself and you
can really sort of pace the game out at
least for your team
exactly how you want it to go which you
know some so i think some people are
sort of
um internally we've had people like kind
of worried about that pressure a little
bit like oh man that's a lot of like i
have a lot of responsibility now but i
think
as you start to play it and you realize
like wow i actually have a lot more
tools to do this than before
though i mean i'm a lot stronger i can
actually survive these encounters a lot
more especially with
healers both focusing on me now and
everything so um
it ends up just kind of being empowering
and super fun when you get in there
um especially obviously with the ability
to cancel reinhardt charges up so you
don't have to over commit
and uh you can poke a little bit with
winston's even have to over commit with
them either so
a lot more control yeah i mean yeah i
agree
yeah oh sorry earlier i mentioned i used
to be a brian main
as well so
it took me a while to get used to the
changes but it i agree with but jeff
said there's a lot more choice and
tactical decisions you're making as the
tank now
that it just feels fun and really good
for the team
i love that you used to mention uh
reinhardt here as well because i know
something that maybe haven't covered
a great depth so far but because the
role of the tank
maybe changes or maybe it becomes more
focused now to some degree
um you know reinhardt obviously we've
known him to have a sort of a passive
ability
on live where he's less affected by some
of this crowd control or knock back
stuff oh yeah i want to talk a bit about
role passes because that's something
that is uh you know is coming to
overwatch too and
really sort of sets some of these roles
apart from each other a bit more jeff
yeah so this is um anything coming to
overwatch too it's um
for those that don't know it's every
role so tanks dps and support
get a passive or a set of passives
related to their role
so in this case you can see uh tanks
have a couple things
uh associated with them one is they're
reduced
they hit knockback uh reduction on them
so you can't knock them around quite so
easily which thematically makes sense
too but
if you're a tank player you're playing
against you know lucio and you know
whoever else it can be really
infuriating sometimes just be flying
around all the time not be able to
control your character as well
so that's uh one of the things they get
the other thing they get that we
heard about tanks especially tanks like
roadhog don't have a barrier
is people feel like they generate too
much ultimate for the enemy team
especially if you're trying to be
aggressive which is what we're trying to
incentivize that you come in you do
maybe you cancel charge and try to get
hammer swings in there to build your old
but like
did you was that a worthwhile trade-off
if the enemy shot you so much that they
built more old than you did so
what we've done is shooting an enemy
tank generates less hold for you
so your enemies get less hope for
shooting you across the board for all
tanks now
these are obviously the values where
they're tuning but you can kind of see
it here a little bit
you know depending on your shooting you
can generate a lot of assault
and then for dps players uh the role
passive they get right now and this is
something we're definitely iterating on
a tuning
maybe even more aggressive than the
other ones is they get a movement speed
bonus just across the board which you
can see here
um you can see it's not like massive
it's not like everyone's gonna be
soldier sprinting around the map or
anything um but we have found so far
like i mean a players probably test this
too like any kind of movement to be
changes to anything is huge like
yeah this is why lucio was considered
sort of like you know
mandatory for so long because he was the
only one bringing move speed and i
granted his a lot more move speed but
um so we started a little higher we were
tuning it back a little bit we're trying
to find the number here but
um it's really interesting in what
allows you to do as far as
even just like basic map traversals you
can just flank a lot easier and not
you don't have to commit as much time to
the flank and to get back uh but also
like there are times where let's say
you're like reaper or something
and you commit your resources to to get
at an enemy zenyatta or something
and he's trying to run around the corner
just get away from you and you know you
could just catch him
i mean given enough a little bit of time
you'll just get up close to him and you
know close that gap so um that's
pretty powerful uh even though it's kind
of a little subtle there
um and then the the support changes
is this is probably something that on a
mains especially you're gonna love to
hear
but the support players all get
automatic health regen
after a certain amount of time without
taking damage which is basically the
nightmare
that's great right exactly so it's
mercy's passive but
a lot less of a degree and mercy's
passive will still exist as a much
stronger version
but this is still there so you know you
know i always feel like you're an auto
player
you know obviously when you're really
low you're like i guess i'll leave
myself but sometimes you're missing like
50 health and you're like uh am i going
to waste my need just to hear myself
where's my other healer
in front of you as well so like i have
to turn around
exactly so um that's been really awesome
especially
for us um designing new heroes because i
feel like we're in this position every
time we design a new healer
it's like okay well we have to come up
with some mechanic that they can heal
themselves because it's like ridiculous
that you can't like
you know shoot yourself in the foot or
whatever was always on a joke but um
so now now they have to sort of like you
don't have to worry about that anymore
unless we wanted to add
something like mercy's case or even
zenyatta's case for shields shields
regenerate
on top of this so you'll actually get
double regen uh if you're if your
shields are regening
so there are those heroes still retain
their sort of extra regeneration bonuses
but
it's a lot nicer for ana now of course
on the horizon we're going to be showing
more of our of our new maps here in
overwatch two but something i noticed
that kind of
kind of snuck past us here some uh some
footage of may
so because may seems like she's been
changed pretty drastically at least uh
in terms of how she operates
so this is actually the kind of tip of
the iceberg and some changes i could
talk about but
mae was the the first one we sort of
checked into the build and we wanted to
play with for a long time so
if you notice here she doesn't actually
fully freeze the enemy here at all she
still slows down
but she doesn't never never go twist
your compensation of courses does a lot
more damage so it's
you know it's really scary to be getting
hit by her because you're taking damage
and you're slow
but of course there's a lot of ways to
escape you can have help and everything
but you never actually get in that
lockdown stage like okay well here's the
free headshot i guess i'm dead
um you know and for her it's really
interesting too because
she still has at least right now she
still has that sort of cleave effect the
piercing that can hit multiple targets
so if you're doing so much damage now if
you can it's kind of fun to play this
game and try to get
all this extra damage because good
straight up just kill people now by
piercing through tank or you know
certainly if zarya's old thing or
something like that you can just pierce
everybody just killing yourself
so it's kind of the interesting uh still
has an interesting back and forth with
her secondary fire as well
but as i mentioned it's kind of the tip
of the iceberg because
um what we're really playing around with
and this isn't actually in this build
this is something
we've been experimenting with uh hasn't
quite been
successful enough to quite put into the
build yet but this is something we're
looking at
is just generally looking at crowd
control across the whole game like where
do we want it to be
who should have it um because we
certainly are we've got feedback over
time we totally
understand respect like sometimes you're
playing against you know the ultimate cc
team with like
may and i don't know mccree and whatever
and especially as a tank i'm sure you're
well aware of this and you're just like
oh my god i hate my life
um
[Laughter]
experimenting with uh like just
generally setting guidelines like
okay tanks should probably have cc
they're all about space control
and you know they have that role to be
able to earth shatter or
you know create that um those great
opportunities
but should as many dps heroes have cc it
may
maybe mccree doesn't need a stun you
know and and so we're looking at all
all of these especially the mostly
actually really the dps and the supports
um currently like again this is all like
really hot the presses because it's not
even in this build but
um we're probably thinking that like
anna's pretty cool right now
people are generally pretty cool with
her sleep um it's a skill shot element
involved
a lot of if you won't just keep going
how about like a
fan of snakes
it give me cool talent ideas actually um
but uh
so like that you know we're still
playing that one seems pretty cool but
like
mccree probably not so cool even though
he's sort of like ingrained on the
korean side of the song that's like what
he's about but it's like
okay well what if he didn't would have
had something else or whatever worked a
different way
um of course that almost has as many
ramifications as the tank changes
because it's like now we're talking
about
okay we take all the cc away tracer
doomfist
wrecking ball these heroes are just like
out of control now right because like
they're sort of heavily countered by cc
so
then we got to go back and change those
heroes of course as well as the
compensation for the cc heroes so
that is something that's heavily in
progress and uh i'm hopeful that um i
think we'll be able to get some
reductions in there i'm sure
i think a lot of our fans would like to
see it um
so trying to you know a lot of these
changes including the tensions are
trying to get back to like
you know core shooter roots it
definitely feels like jeff um
you know we we were at points were
wondering is this game like a mobile
like how important is that positioning
the ability usage element how important
is the the the shooting uh element
it's not uncommon for you know you know
for developers to say this game's all
you know it's about the gun play but as
the game
evolves and you have these ideas and you
bring these new abilities in that it can
sort of change that
super um usually mate it's hard to get
you to uh stop talking but uh you've had
a moment to absorb some of this
let's let's talk about how you think the
role
of the main tank or tank in this regard
is gonna change
in maybe an overwatch too and sort of
some of your thoughts about where the cc
is going
how's it going to feel you know you have
a rock out mental dude like the way you
you sit on that stream and you just go
go but tell us how you think this sort
of changes
yeah uh so that was kind of a big worry
of mine was like you say one tank
and i'm thinking current overwatch where
you know you're playing against a brig
and then an honor and a mccree and a may
and then you know you're stunned locked
for 17 seconds then you want to alt f4
um but if they're you know if it is you
know looking at the rest of the
the the cc in the game and you're
looking to reduce that across the board
and then on top of that you're adding
more utility to tanks i think that's
you know it's going to make it easier to
do that um because i i
i have felt that cc is kind of um
it's a little out there sometimes you
know it's it's not always the most fun
to play against
um and especially for me i always felt
that displacement cc
was almost more egregious than like
stuns because like if you get booped by
like a lucio and like a brig whip shot
or a ball that can like swing back and
forth
i always felt that that was more um like
annoying and frustrating to play against
because
you you couldn't really control that
like you kind of just got knocked
everywhere and that was just the way it
was
um are those being like looked at as
well as stuns or
is it like everything across the board
yeah definitely but the nice thing is we
have this new tuning knob of the tank
passives to say
you know if we still want lucio to be
able to boop enemies off cliffs or
something to leave that strong
but we still we still think tanks are
being booted too much we can just dial
that like
knockback reduction up a little bit for
the tanks so they you know they they're
less affected by it
so it's a nice place to be absolutely
all right that's
that's nice to hear i mean yeah we're
drilling down pretty heavily into like
you know what
what it means to be a tank player and i
think talking about it is good but
i kind of want to see some more more of
it in action um i mean dion
we have i mean i can see it here in a
little preview screen but our next map
is is really incredible and it really
captures i think the vervacity and
vibrance of uh
of of a region the world that's really
known for it talkers talk to us through
uh this map that is real
yeah so real another map we wanted to do
for a long time
we have several artists on the team that
that spent the part of their life there
so it's pretty fun to kind of dive in
and see
this overwatch version of rio did the
beautifully painted favelas colorful
vibrant club you get to visit where
lucille's club is
the team loves going to brazilian
barbecue so one of the spawn rooms is a
brazilian barbecue place you know it's
another map we're just having a lot of
fun creating different details
and and this aspirational version of
this location for overwatch too
and it's a a brand new payload here too
you guys saw earlier it's a pretty fun
carnival float
so we're just having fun with these maps
they need cool brazilian barbecue
it's uh fun and sunny and colorful and i
think it's a map that
feels like overwatch when you play it
you know i mean
already that sort of signature vibrance
that you know so many of
uh you know overwatch's maps have been
credited for is there can you
i obviously i don't want you to give
away too much too much of the story but
is there a context here like where are
the attackers starting from because i
see some beach i see different
landscapes sort of getting fleshed out
here
as we go through the map okay so the
defense actually starts in lucio's home
so yeah obviously there's a story later
that overwatch
that we want to tell so lucio plays a
big part of that so
you get a little hint of where we're
going with that but we're
not talking too heavily about it also
lucio's club is always it's kind of a
community place so it's a place
and if it was real people can come there
for free
he's a community guy we wanted to
showcase this with this
gigantic kind of sci-fi club he has
um yeah it's it's connected to the story
of overwatch uh you will just have to
wait and see
how closely rio plays into the game you
saw a little bit at blizzcon
a while ago but um there's definitely
more
all right so i uh i do have a question
for jeff sorry to cut you off
but i do have a question if that's fine
so if i'm pretty sure like way back in
the day there was like an interview that
i read that was like
five was too small and seven was too big
for the
roster limit and then six was perfect
but like i'm kind of curious like where
along like the overwatch timeline that
that philosophy kind of changed like was
it roll lock was it like
people learning how to play the game
better like
pretty much all of this yeah i mean it's
i mean we know so much about the game i
mean it's kind of aaron touched on the
beginning like
before everything and you could just
play five winstons in fact we had an
internal tournament where that was your
strategy was sort of like oh my god this
seems like maybe a problem or is this
cool we don't know
uh so like obviously when you're
building really any game
you try to make the best gestures for
what you have and what you're playing
but
once you have the game in the wild you
get everybody else's hands and it
marinates for a while you're making
changes like your opinion on the stuff
definitely changes so
i think over time um like it was
touchdown we were still keeping an open
mind to
maybe doing some of these kind of
changes and then coming over watch two
we were just like
let's revisit everything and that was
definitely one of the major core
decisions over watch when we were
really looking forward to visiting and
at that point we were just like yeah
maybe this is actually just
much better maybe we were wrong all
along although people always say
it's kind of a design thing people say
you're not necessarily wrong at the time
just because you were wrong in
retrospect
yeah but uh yeah
so obviously this is a hybrid now i
don't know if i mentioned that at the
beginning here so
um much in the same way as king's row
we'll be fighting for control of a
payload here which will eventually
roll on out and we kind of teased uh
yeah so
these payloads this is i mean i'm no
stranger to peacocking look at what i'm
wearing but this is uh
this is great obviously we tell a story
in overwatch
in overwatch one with with these
payloads here so looking forward to
seeing how that story gets fleshed out
what i'm seeing already is real
difference in uh map geometry right as
we move into the second phase
all of a sudden it's less about chokes
and overpasses and it's just this
this this jumble of all these buildings
and so much high ground here
really feel like yeah the way you play
the map changes drastically here
yeah oh you can go ahead
oh that was just one thing we're we're
trying more of this
phased approach with the visuals and the
gameplay as we move through the space
so you saw it was a bit more open as you
get the payload there's a feeling of
changing gameplay and art as well
so this visual progression as well as
gameplay
it's much more clear in some of the
newer maps we're working on
yeah one thing that i maybe it's just
maybe it's just a coincidence but i feel
like
a lot of a lot of chokes in in in
overwatch one like specifically like i
think like hanamura first or like
going through kings row second they're
very like tight and like
it's like perfect for like a reinhardt
shield to spread across and it can be
like
you know a real pain to get through
those sometimes because you feel like
you really only have like
one way to go through but i'm seeing at
least in the other two maps that we
looked at a lot more
uh a lot more flanks and ways to access
the point
and i think that's overall better for
the design because
i feel like when you especially on
hanuma at first like going through that
choke is kind of
you know it can be a real it could be
real not fun sometimes
if you're just not clicking or if it's
just you know they have a hard comp that
that yours can't counter and i think
it's just better overall
yeah if we want to give players more
options to solve a problem and say
they're stuck at the choke
they have a few more options to break
through basically they don't have to
rely
fully on the tank powering through this
time but
yeah that's that's always the thing
we're trying to improve the options the
players have to solve
situations are there are going to be
previous maps in overwatch one that will
be reworked or
uh we don't know can you not say is that
secret
i don't know i don't know okay fair
enough
so obviously you look you've got you've
got one less hero on the battlefield uh
your maps are
much more uh labyrinthine i guess or
just bigger right it's just a large
you know there's so much more ground you
could cover if you wanted to take a
different approach
uh how do you sort of balance how big
the map is right because obviously
there's a sense where like
you know if you go too far one direction
right it can seem quite barren but here
like
everything there's attention to detail
everywhere right there's so many
criss-crossing ways of approaching the
point um
so it doesn't feel big but it definitely
uh as opposed to massive store in
in in overwatch in on live right now it
definitely feels bigger right is that
ever a consideration trying to balance
that the sort of size and
the majesty of it all uh yeah
it's definitely more detailed than
before
and again the more options there's more
passageways and buildings for players
to move through and build strategies
from but
ultimately the maps are in a fairly
similar size to
the previous you're just seeing a lot
more detail on the overwatch 2 engine we
have a lot of cool upgrades
that allow us to do more while keeping a
smooth performance
but yeah it's something we're constantly
playing with us at the scale of maps and
and how it feels to move through the
space visually as well as gameplay-wise
this really has like a dorado feel
almost right we have sort of
payloads that are moving through
underneath and there are there are
multiple levels here this is not just
sort of two levels here you can there's
even more options i guess to sort of
make use of this verticality
yeah left high ground right high ground
there's so much going on here
i love this point in particular like
taking that middle high ground is
you know really important if you can
hold it it's fantastic but it's just
really hard to hold because you have all
these
upper flank routes and under flank
routes and stuff so
uh it ends up being like kind of a
gambit to try to even take it and hold
it especially when you don't have
tanks that can just sit on it with
barriers all the time um but it's so
powerful you can see where widow is
right there it's so powerful you have to
land a sight on everything up there
is is universal charge nerfed or is it
just as a result of the tank changes
that it seems like people are getting
their old slower
it's mostly just the tanks and we don't
have they're probably i can't remember
exactly all the individual changes but i
think we probably adjusted a few
heroes here and there may have gone up
or down on their costs but
it's almost entirely just the tank
changes generate a lot of ulta
tanks right i guess there's one less
tank to shoot as well so it makes it
a little bit harder although looking at
widow's interesting example we haven't
adjusted the snipers too much yet but
we're keeping a really close eye on them
because
a lot of what sort of controls snipers
is the
that fact there's all these barriers you
can't shoot through when you're playing
as widow against the comp that is
you know like back in the day when it
was like wrecking ball only or something
like that like
you definitely are a lot more powerful
so uh yeah
they're not they don't get out of
control i feel because i feel like on
some of these choke points it's
definitely a lot more wider
than than some other maps and i feel
like uh
you know if unchecked some certain
widows could do a lot of damage
yeah yeah so yeah just yet another thing
we have to keep an eye on with
change like this right i mean you know
we we talk about how sort of tanks have
changed now to sort of allow them to be
more
multi-purpose or sort of fill a broader
spectrum of roles obviously like
you know when you have a reinhardt you
kind of know what the player is playing
for right the shield
creates space right you create space
just because the shield exists and
if someone like roadhog um they create
space because of the threat of the hook
right it's not even something that's
necessarily it's implied threat right
it's not
um exactly directly displayed so i mean
what is the idea for a tank do you still
want there to be the mix of their sort
of being that implied threat plus
obviously a very visible
threat you know has it changed the way
you think about how tanks
create spaces now obviously all tanks
have to be able to do that to some
degree regardless if they have a shield
or not
yeah absolutely and obviously also
impacts new hero design
working here is how they're going to act
with creating space and
defending their team um certainly
looking at
uh you know erisa's not being played
here for a reason because we're looking
at her really heavily
um any hero that has sort of that just a
really kind of
heavy static slow defense are the ones
we're kind of trying to hit the hardest
first
um and then you know just that alone
already
makes roadhog shine a little bit because
he's not being compared to
the huge barrier reinhardt um but
certainly yeah
should have healed their first probably
but you know you went for it um
yeah so like there's a lot of change we
can make now in this world that
would have been really scary to make
before um especially in regards to
cooldowns uh so like roadhog
used to have a much faster hook way back
in the day
um maybe we could bring that back uh
especially in a world where all the
tanks are pretty aggressive because it
you know it doesn't feel like it's super
crazy uh we still want to make sure
there's nothing like counter play you
want to feel like
i made him dodge the hook and then we
had no opportunity to attack it was
hooked again right afterwards so
certainly a balancing act but um a lot
of the the tank
uh sort of tankiness can be just in the
hero themselves now
because if you get to go in and be
threatening like with all this extra
damage and just
be hard to kill space by existing
what an animal obviously um
super i'm curious with your opinion here
obviously someone plays tank right and
you know you'll play uh your main tank
as we called it or i'll think
what is it that makes you sort of feel
most powerful when you're playing tank
right because obviously all the heroes
offer something so different each of
them both could you
narrow down or something what makes you
feel like mtd feel you know
yeah uh well i feel like a lot of it
comes down to like
decision making right and a lot of that
currently is kind of based off of the
fact of what your
second tank is doing which is obviously
uh you know no longer a thing
because there's a removal um and i feel
like this is really gonna have to rely a
lot more on like
your supports keeping you a lot more
alive as opposed to like your off tank
or
secondary tank you know being in
in coordination with you um because the
supports now they only have to focus on
on one tank in particular
um as opposed to you know having to
split between two
and i i feel like that's probably going
to have to
give a lot more tanks have to play a lot
more
i guess assertive because they can't
really
rely on on their other tank to make the
decisions for them
or like to you know help them out in
that way
i feel like a definitely i know you know
there's a
a good handful of players who you know
their selection of tank
really boils down to their capacity to
deal damage
uh you know like a lot like you got you
you'll see them right you get these
weird sort of
sigma's are you comfortable you see like
a lot of people just like playing
roadhog that's their favorite thing
because he does damage
um you know trying to make you know
a player feel powerful on tank without
just doing damage requires you to really
think much more about games
that's what i kind of wanted you like
outside of just doing a ton of damage
how do you sort of balance a tank to
make them feel powerful without just
pumping numbers into their primary fire
yeah uh i think that's probably a design
philosophy
uh that i'm maybe not qualified to talk
about
um because i wasn't actually asking you
but you can weigh in on it
it's not speaking that's good no it's
good
um yeah i mean a lot of it's like we're
talking about with just options and like
you know super mentioned
like i'm trying to make sure that i mean
that's kind of the point of the zarya
change
is just giving her more flexibility and
more options so i mean
it happens to be a she also generates a
lot more energy and is way scarier it
does more damage in this case
uh we may have to rain that in a little
bit she was already running out on that
last
a little bit there with like 80 and 100
so you can see it's pretty pretty
aggressive but
um yeah it's definitely just trying to
create um
really interesting play-making
opportunities and just strategic thought
and i think that's where a lot of
people kind of like to have the tanks
exist where it's
if you really want to just click heads
there are probably better options out
there i don't think
i don't think we're likely to make any
kind of like sniper tank out there
anything like that because
you know there's a lot of other
opportunities for that um we'd like to
try to get the tanks like
like i was mentioning the crowd control
changes as an example of this let's keep
the tanks
beating the ones who are primarily able
to do crowd control
and that's also with only being one tank
now it means still there's gonna be a
lot less
crowd control in the game uh in general
but still allow them to
sort of flex that particular element
right so you talk about obviously
taking a little bit of that away from me
but obviously it's still something that
you know you feel like you could include
in the game it almost feels like it's
a more moderated approach to it now
because tanks can
can be the ones that bear a lot of that
sort of crowd control uh potential
just means that there's you know now
it's just that one hero on the
battlefield that really is able to
produce
so much of that outside of you know five
different forms that are coming in
so it feels like almost exactly
responsibility as a as a tank player is
almost
kicked up a notch there because you got
to be a jack of all trades in some cases
especially if crowd control gets reduced
to a point where
you're looking for a to counter
something specific like you're looking
for
genji blade then you know it's ready and
you're going you need to let's say
you're playing hog you like
really want to land that hook when he
comes in um it's a really big game
changer if you land it
um so sort of like make sure it's up and
then you save it try and keep an eye on
him
um and conversely if you're a character
who is really watching for you know like
reaper something like that wants to get
a zolt off but you want to make sure
you're not going to get stunned
it's a lot easier to sort of track who
who's
can stop you you're looking for their
tank and looking for
um rather than looking at the hole in
the team it's kind of like when you're
sorry you're trying to alternate you're
watching diva really close because you
don't want to have it eaten
and that's what you're most concerned
with as far as timing goes it's like
that with more cc in general
guys nuts on red hog yeah even even with
sort of yet less knockout ryan obviously
being as close as he was to the whole
gets knocked away
um i i still remember i almost it was
almost like a tooltip text loading into
game
uh sort of playing overwatch that sort
of said like listen out for footsteps
like the heavier footsteps mean your
opponent is potentially
more dangerous to you but it definitely
feels like
you know the weight of these weapons is
much
more effectively conveyed right if i'm
listening here as we're sort of talking
um like that scrub gun sounds extremely
meaty
i love the weapon sounds yeah such a
great job
and they uh especially like soldier oh
widow yeah what else
the sort of like that going sound you
shoot in an open space oh my god it's
fantastic
you really feel like you're actually
building a very high caliber weapon
right that actually has weight and it
has a sense of kick back and
and uh sort of makes sound and also like
it based on where you are
in the map you know the environment yeah
i think this may be covered i think this
one online as well but it really feels
like the environment
we were inside you know club um in
lucio's club beforehand and that echo is
really much more apparent right that
yeah environment playing a big role in
how things sound
and being on the receiving end of
widowmaker's shot it just feels so much
more dangerous hearing the sound
so it helps you hide basically
right height and terror that's a sorry
that's a big part of it as well like
it's not just when you when you fire but
you're getting hit by
these these weapons and these abilities
seems like it
yeah it has more of an impact it's not
like we're you know yeah we're giving
you an earthquake in your safer
um you know i feel like i'm almost sort
of shifting in my seat as
people getting hit by stuff here is
doomfist lance punches
much more visceral experience right
oh yeah i mean it adds so much i mean
there's so much done to
um i mean i'm certainly not an audio guy
but i've talked to them a lot and what
they've been working on but
i they've been given the ability to
create more accurate sounds in more in
in certain spaces so
like an indoor tighter area or an indoor
wider area can have different sounds and
get that sort of
sound of things bouncing off the walls
and it's it's so epic and
not only does it make the game feel a
lot better as far as like your weapons
and getting shot at but like it actually
makes the environment feel a lot better
because you feel more connected
like you're actually in that space just
the way yeah all the sounds are playing
when you're in that space
the immersion of the environment too
that's just the sounds of the
environment
is oh yeah it's beautiful now
if we could just walk through without
all the bullets yeah i mean it's only
exactly right not so tranquil i guess
when you're when you're fighting for
your life with uh nine other people
superman i mean naturally you know these
are changes that you know some of them
you thought about before
obviously having played so much tank and
maybe you wish for some of these and
uh you know i'd love to get some of your
final thoughts here on sort of how tank
is gonna feel and
heading into overwatch tours i'm sure
you'll be uh you'll be strapped in
and uh playing um
i don't know i mean i i feel like i have
to get a chance to play it first but
uh based on what based on what i've seen
it looks like uh
you know tanks gonna have a lot more
pressure i feel like or a lot more of a
role
uh to play because you know you don't
really have that second
uh that second tank to help you out and
you know kind of help clean up your
mistakes if you will like you know if
you could hook you get a bubble or
matrix or you know whatever it may be so
i feel like in general it looks like
tanks are going to play a lot smarter
um but you do get the plus side of
having both supports
only focus on you as opposed to having
two so i think it'll be interesting
well uh we're interested to hear some of
your thoughts of course as the live
stream goes and
uh as we get further and further down
the development roadmap as well as some
of these changes get fleshed out even
more super
thank you very much for joining us mate
obviously i'll be seeing you soon once
the the shock get back
on the battlefield uh we're good to have
you here and uh yeah we'll see you soon
man
thank you for having me appreciate it
yeah thank you super thanks
and uh that was course was uh matthew
super duly i was the tank player from
the san francisco shock and has
given us some really good insights as
well maybe on on how it feels for him to
see these
tank changes i want to now take the
opportunity to welcome to
our stream obviously prolific streamer
cupcake obviously we see you play a
multitude of fps titles including
overwatch
uh great to have you with us cupcake a
lot of news today we're continuing to
tease more out of these devs slowly
i'd love to get some of your thoughts on
what we have so far
oh man i really like seeing all the new
like hero looks and like the map visuals
and the ui updates have been really cool
especially as like a support player
i'm seeing a lot of little like ui
updates for like support heroes and i'm
really excited about them
so yeah absolutely you and me both
obviously i'm a support mate as well so
i'm looking forward to teasing
a little bit more uh out of our out of
our devs not only of course about
maybe supports but a little bit more
about overwatch too and of course yes we
will be showing
uh another map in just a moment so let's
take the opportunity to uh to sort of
bring
uh these these devs back in of course
obviously
uh jeff and dion have given us some uh
great thoughts so far because something
that was teased at blizzcon online
uh and we got to see a little bit of was
actually the hero looks right overwatch
2
is you know it's a game that's set a
little bit further
sort of in the future as far as we can
tell and this is reflected
in what the heroes actually look like i
don't know if deon jeff if you can
sort of speak to that because uh it's
not just a like a
a jazzy tech upgrade but something you
know we can see the passage of time
being implied with some of these new
looks
yeah thank you that's part of it is the
passage of time you can see bro
reinhardt is a little older i think
there's a
sneak peek at a few characters that um
there's a bit of age difference on them
as well a bunch of guys are part of
overwatch now so they
have access to cooler tech in their
outfits
uh it's just we're having fun kind of
like
in a way to show these guys have
upgraded their equipment
they're ready to do battle in this new
world fire here with their new overwatch
gear so that she has the armor that
fits the overwatch team uh
yeah and just reaper is pretty amazing
as well
the definitely feeling of them looking
sort of more high tech in a sense as
well yeah so
i mean you know i love that you kind of
you kind of this is cheeky you're kind
of teasing uh little bits of the story
or how the world changes out as we go so
that's just
you know building my appetite up to to
sort of see more about how the world is
changing and what all these
heroes are up to i mean you see
obviously widowmaker's got a change of
hairstyle as well
um tell us about what the development
process
on these changes is like because i think
we sort of mentioned that there's sort
of new tech available to developers to
sort of bring
these characters to life but i'd love to
know how you go about
refreshing or revamping or update some
of these hero looks
yeah we have a lot of cool very really
cool engine up
upgrades that you could see in some of
those shots
a lot of better detail the characters
skin feel more natural
their hair has a really awesome shader
and it just it you know it's still
stylized but it just feels much more
real
almost like you could touch it uh this
is in the environments as well there's
tons of nice detail we've upgraded the
lighting engine
so shadows are better all these things
are just to make the world feel much
more
immersive more dynamic and more animated
things in the world uh the characters
have the
cool tech gear and details that we
weren't able to do before until
we kind of turned tuned some knobs in
the engine and
so we're suddenly playing with this
maintaining overwatch style
keeping the game performance smooth but
you know upgrading everything to the
overwatch 2 level
i'm curious about like the new the new
upgrades to the skins and like just the
heroes themselves
and you guys have all the skins from all
the different heroes from
overwatch and like how challenging it is
to bring them
in and like update their looks as well
like is that an easy process or is it
like tedious to make them all look
just as good that's a great question um
so a lot of the tech
we for example the skin shader will
apply to all the older skins as well
so our engine team is working hard to
kind of create a workflow that's easier
for the artist but it's still there's
there's a level of work there but
everything you see on these new 2.0
heroes the
updated hair shaders updated skin uh
detail maps
these will all carry over to the older
um heroes or the older skins
so a lot of stuff looks even better than
it did before
yeah i can only imagine there's a bit of
work there to apply
some of the new new um techniques to
those guys but
it's a beautiful upgrade to practically
every single skin in the game
so it'll be fun for players to see
is it going to be possible to like add
more customization
like with this new technology like
unlocking different like color schemes
or something like that or like special
weapon variations even for like
certain achievements or something like
that so we have more ways to customize
the way our heroes
look an amazing question but i
you have to wait and see
what about like mixing and matching like
skins and weapons is that going to
be impossible like 11 from one skin
because like that would be so much fun
like you get creative with that can you
imagine
like oh man now i mean we're already
we're theorycrafting you know we're off
to the races here already
i'm like i have so many ideas there's a
lot of fun stuff in store
yeah you do have something new it's like
my favorite part is the visual
so well speaking of which okay dion has
uh a new hero
to show us dion do you want to talk us
through this one
yeah so this one will be
i think he's a torbjorn so this is
tourbillon 2.0
you can see he's nice he's a little
older he has a
bit better technology and gear and
yeah he's uh the torbjorn we all know
and loves he's just
much more in advance he has a cool
very cool you can see the hair shaving
really well on his uh beard
but like imagine that but with like his
summer skin like weapon
like that's the kind of stuff i want to
see at some point
so that i mean you can you can
definitely see i mean some of the some
of the changes are big right they're
vibrant and obviously
you know you can definitely see the
passenger and some are subtle
you know it's the it's the patches on
the knees of his jeans it's the
connectors between
the hardware that he's using uh the
goggles that he has
um and i mean we can see this gregarious
uh attitude from him very clearly
displayed though i think that's very
much still been
brought to life and you know we want to
upgrade the characters
but we don't want to lose that
silhouette that's familiar to players
you know
he still looks like torbjorn from a
distance he just looks
better and more detailed up close but he
maintains that
silhouette we come to know and love and
like to shoot at
so um that's uh some of the extra
extra props the vfx team for doing some
like the next uh kind of 2.0 vfx on his
pack there looks great
right smoke coming off yeah it's a
serious modernization of
of you know yeah not just obviously how
his skins look but how he behaves in the
game and how he interfaces with the
world that he's put in
let's let's shift gear here and talk a
little bit more about our next map
rome was teased the blizzcon online
right we got these beautiful panoramas
these colosseum looking things just like
sort of this sort of future rome but
um that is that's obviously uh coming up
next and it needs a push map so i want
to talk
a little bit more about how a push map
is actually developed right the newest
game type to the game
um there's some really unique situations
to play through
but let's delve in a bit deeper i have
to assume right like there's there has
to be some
symmetry to the map i'm sure that's is
that sort of right
okay what's important designing push map
let's start there
so symmetry is obviously the number one
important
part it makes it very competitive
because both sides have a similar
layout but it also makes it tough to
create a second one so
you had toronto that we saw earlier
where it was more of an s curve
layout to the battle in rome you'll see
it's
kind of a sea you kind of cut through
the coliseum
it becomes tighter when you reach the
robot
once you see the players play this one
was where we really found the way
okay this is how we make iterations on
push
if at first the s-curve was a an easy
one to go to you know it's
make the map snake through buildings and
things
but how do we switch it up for a
different space and
we knew we wanted to make rome we knew
we wanted to go through the coliseum so
that's kind of part of the initial
design for this
version the push map but it's a very fun
mode especially on um
in rome i think the thematic of the
scene plus pushing the robot
kind of enhances how fun this game type
is
it's such a crazy just a position
between all the sci-fi movies that you
might watch and then a location that is
obviously known to us and sort of
thinking about how
you know that the passage of time might
change it i want to know um you know
you mentioned the first thing you
mentioned dion i feel like was that like
it's very competitive as a result of
that symmetry
and you guys as the developer team on
overwatch have had a good chance to see
how
so many of these maps play out at the
highest competitive level so i'm curious
to know like
how much is al over rather overwatch
league of factor when you're sort of
considering
a game type for a map design like this
you know how often you think oh like how
the players could break this or you know
they're gonna
sort of you know go for the one percent
plays on this kind of map is does that
factor into the
their process all that much
absolutely yeah for sure jeff you're
probably into this man
yeah i mean they um certainly i feel
like
it's hard to imagine a player base sort
of
breaking a map apart probably as much as
the overwatch teams
league teams do they will find that
stuff fast and it uses
even the smallest things um so yeah i
mean we definitely
as far as like the the specific layout
we're looking at a lot of stuff
uh quite a bit but especially we're
developing a new mode um
it's very much taken into account how
competitive it's going to be and as
was brought up earlier um you know based
on the rule set we want to make sure
if we can avoid it we want to avoid any
kind of tie situation and this
this mode certainly prevents that and
then as aaron was talking about earlier
like we were debating whether or not
this should be like
kind of easy to push to the end and then
you know you get a point and then the
other team can
you know maybe it's multiple rounds and
each push is one point but then it's
like
you get in that potential tie situation
and this you lose some of that sort of
sort of epic tension of um pushing it
those last little bits and people
fighting over those a little bit of
space and
um so i think uh yeah we're very
cognizant
especially with new modes thinking about
how they're gonna be played and
competitive we had
so many uh matches that came down to two
three meters this
is such a fun just you feel good
even luke you know you're like that was
a great battle because
it felt like we fought really hard for
those last two three meters
this map is genetically engineered for
play-by-play casters i like that
more opportunities for us to just yell
nonsense uh we're gonna jump in and
check this one out
we've got a bunch more questions i'm
sure carca you do as well here but i
mean first impression is
is wow this is an incredible vista
beautiful
thank you wow absolutely stunning stuff
we talked about you know you mentioned
like the s-shape sort of thing but it
looks like this
there's some twists and turns here it's
almost like the path
overlaps itself as well at some points
it does there's a little bit of c-shape
and then there's this bridge overpass
that's
pretty fun to encounter i think i'm
curious to see how this battle plays out
once the players get to the overpass
i feel like the two big features on this
map and we'll see
right away is the first one is right in
the
uh under the coliseum basically where
the uh or
the uh are the bot starts
and uh that it's it you know it kind of
like
um looks sort of simple and basic
geometry but it's like
the the subtlety there is it's got a
slight curve to it the whole time
it's so amazing and you can see certain
of these are blocked off and certain of
them are open
um as far as in between the pillars and
that was actually iterated on quite a
bit i remember
um opening them up closing them in fact
you see the tops are actually open so
you can climb over fly over them so
we still allow some flanking routes if
you're like a pharah or genji and you
want to get cheeky
um but we didn't want to close it off
entirely so that one section
was sort of everyone's favorite right
away in play testing um
and then just that a massive amount
iteration on it was great
right so we'll see it here that quality
of life trains on winston's bubble
it does not go unnoticed by the way the
duration of the bubble remaining
uh being shown on the hud is huge
oh yeah yeah
i love that that's funny watching sorry
i mean just like the curvature actually
sort of
it actually reduces line of sight right
so you cannot just sit at one end of
this this sort of track
and see the other if you're a sniper so
even that
small tweet you know has balance
implications that i'm sure
you've thought about to quite a great
degree i think um
it gives me a cupcake of both support
mains i think something we we're
definitely gonna be
wanting to talk about here is that it's
not just zenyatta's hud that's
that's gotten a change right it seems
like every sport
looks a little bit different when it
comes to the hud and some of those
abilities that interact with teammates
yeah which like does even the zen
placement of the orbs
uh it's so much better like more in the
middle rather than having it on this
side
um i think that's really nice i've
noticed like the little
changes with like having mercy like it
shows when mercy's healing somebody
a lot more clearly and i like having the
the icons of
who it's on you know um
i like the i wish i would to see more
with
um anna like i would love to see with
anna
having it show like who she slept like
on the ui
yeah like that would be so cool
especially because you know i feel like
i have to tell my dps player that's in
the enemy back line
i don't know if you saw that but i just
looked the fire out the air and then
yeah i like the idea yeah or sometimes
you throw one you don't know who it hit
like you're because there's so much
going on you're like okay i definitely
stopped someone but
i'm not sure who it was uh that might be
important to know
[Music]
that's my fireball you sleep you sleep
against you accidentally with a blade
and someone just wakes them up because
they have no idea
exactly oh no
and obviously you also use player get
indication if mercy is healing or damage
boosting you right obviously
your screen sort of in online your
screen sort of takes on like a sort of a
very slight non-intrusive glow
but it seems here you've also changed
how it's indicated to you that mercy
is is sort of damaged boosting you is
that also the case with like
um a nano boost for example
i can't remember if we've actually
changed the the one p nano boost effect
i don't think um
but the in general there's like you know
great big passive going across
i mean really across the team i mean you
can see the the skin passes and
those emails get sent out all the time
like oh look at these cool skin changes
and you know tech we're getting and then
there's also
vfx updates look at the vfx changes
you're making and sound of course so
it's kind of just awesome being like
even if i'm not directly
you know working on that stuff just sort
of seeing that stuff across my email and
the examples being sent out it's just
awesome like day to day
seeing all the changes i mean yeah i'm
sure your inbox is sort of swarmed with
them
um i i sort of wonder what the oh look
it was mentioned
that blizzcon online as well that sort
of the assault
game mode sort of there wouldn't be sort
of further maps developed for right the
focus would no longer sort of be on that
so
i'd like to know what the sort of
thought process is between sort of the
removal of assault or tcps it's fondly
known
uh and the addition of push here
right so that that's a long history
actually
this probably was uh probably most of
the
people who really follow the game
closely are aware um we've
uh obviously the assault map or tcp is
called um
a lot of people had a lot of concerns
with it and we've tried to make a lot of
changes to it
in fact what people might not know is um
we've gone through multiple
phases of like a heavy overhaul of it
but none of them ever really were good
enough to
go even to experimental card honestly um
i always feel bad because one time we
had a new designer join
and one of the first ones he gave him
was like overhaul
it was like the hardest problem ever go
ahead and solve it you guys
it's like oh that's kind of rough
actually in retrospect
but uh so you know we've got a lot of
went through a lot of changes and
um it got to the point where we're like
we'd have to make so many changes to get
this where we want to be like is it even
the same mode anymore
at that point if we get into that degree
why don't we just make a difference
yeah let's make new why even try to like
you know change it to that degree
so that's kind of how that ended up
going about coming about and
um a lot of it was feedback from the
players
that's kind of spicy jeff you're trying
to say that there's other modes in
development are you trying to imply that
i would say that we're we are constantly
experimenting with lumos
with their experimentation right now
how crazy new york was sorry dylan
please
oh sorry new york was we experimented a
lot with new york
before landing on the mode that we chose
i mean it seems like
there's so many possibilities for that
kind of map right right
temple of anubis when we first showed
that at blizzcon
the shipping version actually changed
you know to try to fix 2cp
even back when the game first came out
uh we actually the version we
shared and the version that shipped with
the game was pretty different
from the chokepoint standpoint to try to
address some of the two cp challenges
so we just left that spot in the mouth
sorry yeah
and that was it yeah oh okay um
i was just gonna comment because we were
there although they just left it but the
other
thing i was mentioning about this map
because i mentioned two things is that
area we just left
was it's like this like corkscrew
basically uh and it's super interesting
yeah it like goes it basically flips on
itself and goes over itself
and uh you can see it coming up here um
so you go under in this case you go to
the right and then back up and then
cross over itself
it is a really interesting point to play
in fact when we were first playing it
i remember we had our first feedback
session was like
i don't know if i like this or not it's
either amazing or it's terrible i can't
even tell
like it's it's super interesting and
very impactful
uh and so we were like i think that
means we keep going with it keep play
testing it and keep iterating so
uh obviously having a big impact is
almost more important if you can get the
good stuff of it
um so after a lot of iteration it's it's
definitely persistent it's become
kind of the most interesting spot to
play around because there's a lot of
drama there
the flanks you can flank from on top to
drop down below because you have to go
under this pass
if you just sit in the middle of that
passes reaper or something like that and
just drop down of course you gotta worry
about gonna be jumping up on you or
something
uh there's actually a little wall on the
right you can climb up right there um
if you're a character that can climb or
a grapple or something
so it's just like this when you're going
through that after playtesting this
mapping out from plain enough when
you're going under that pass it's the
most like
anxiety-inducing spot it's just like
especially when it's like calm for a
while at first because like you know
after a fight and you're going there's
no sounds you're like
okay what is about to happen here where
are they gonna be coming from and it's
like there's a sneaky
little alleyway in there too a tiny one
there's an alleyway there reaper 76
there's a lot of uh so finally
you go through that first or underpass
and you just know it's a little too
quiet
[Laughter]
i mean i'm loving it it looks like i
mean the verticality difference between
sort of playing in this initial sort of
bend and then outside on the corkscrews
is huge like
you'd have to sort of switch columns
almost to try and make the most of it
cupcake
we've seen now a good decent bit of rome
i'd like to get some more of your
thoughts here
oh yeah i mean i think it's absolutely
beautiful i love all the like
architecture and everything in it i was
fascinated when i was watching the
preview during the bliss online on it
and um i would you know love to get in
there and like just go explore it and
look around
and like figure out like
what the best way to go about this is
because there's a lot to
it it's it's a little confusing like
looking at it from like this perspective
but i'm sure once you get in there and
you actually like play it it makes a lot
more sense you know
even with even at 5v5 yeah you
definitely have the feeling of like
franticness or hecticness you know sort
of around the bottom
yeah exactly and this seems like a game
that's catered to like
giving these like adrenaline sort of
pumping moments of overtime right
um oh yeah it seems like there's a lot
of
yeah overtime moments what i love though
is that these buildings don't just seem
to decoration
like even look up at the top right side
right like all these buildings you can
go in so many
so many more of these nooks and crannies
that you can actually
explore that seems like a way more
intense design process as well because
you have to think of everything
you can't leave a stone unturned when
you sort of turn this type of stream
into
you know something vibrant like this
incredible stuff there it is that was
your first look of obviously at some
gameplay on rome
a beautiful map and my god yeah i really
think that uh
those shot callers out there are gonna
have to be thinking a mile a minute just
how they can take advantage of the sort
of topography of the map
as it sort of changes uh really exciting
stuff i mean
we've we already sort of got a feel for
the game mode but it's crazy just how
different i
i don't feel saying cupcake how
different this feels from toronto even
though it's the same
game type but the map sort of changes
the feel and the flow so much
it does yeah it definitely feels a lot
different
um i don't play it like a high-end like
skill level
so i'm curious how it's going to work on
somebody on like
my level like i'm like the average
overwatch player
top 500. like i'm
platt you know a lot a lot of my
overwatch experience as a support like i
solo cue
support you know like it's the struggle
is real and so my experience is like
you know i have my team my tanks are
just like leer boy jenkins in and i'm
like okay here we go and i'm just trying
to like keep up you know
so i'm curious you know how that's going
to go on like as like
flat games you know i mean i'm sure i'm
going to find out because i sure as heck
won't be playing in any other rank than
plat myself
that's what i'm going to be experiencing
really quickly
so y'all know how i feel okay yeah i
mean yeah
i said you're in good company i make no
bones about uh my standing in the game
that was incredible uh thank you jeff
and young for walking us through rome
uh we we started from that sort of
vibrant sort of overlook and then we
were straight into the action i really
love just the
the juxtaposition of sort of the
futuristic tech plus a really historic
location and that's a lot of fun we i
mean speaking of incredible locations we
actually still have one more map to show
everybody so ladies and gentlemen stick
around there's still
more to come a new map an in-depth look
that you haven't heard anything about
coming up on the other side of this
break so stick around for more of this
overwatch 2 pvp
developer live stream
oh
i feel like you man
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
taking the lead
oh let's break it down
all right
welcome back everybody is uh we get
ready for our final
map of the day uh thanks to mitch thanks
all the other uh content creators that
drop by the stream it was a ton of fun
to have them back to the
back to the the original crew though uh
as i know
a lot has changed obviously uh with
overwatch to
pvp uh from i mean a lot of change with
overwatch ones pvp throughout the
eternity but
i think like this is a pretty drastic
kind of change from what the players are
used to
at home uh i guess for the players at
home now like uh you know
what can the expectations be you know
obviously like you guys have mentioned a
lot of this is still work in progress
yeah that's a great it's a it's a great
point to bring up and i think it's um
it's important to recognize that while
we're really excited about a lot of the
changes
that we're making to the game i think
there's probably a lot of people you
know watching the stream
um that can't help but wonder how it how
it's going to affect them
you know and and um like we have a lot
of tank players in the game we have a
lot of off tank
players in the game um and something
that you
that you said resonates with me where
overwatch has changed
over the years um we talked about you
know
before we had hero limits or before we
had rollock you know like
goats was a very popular part of
overwatch
for a long time where it was people were
actually running three tanks
instead of two tanks and i think one of
the one of the things that that has
always been a part of overwatch is
the game does change over time um and i
know that
for some people um it
it's probably jarring to to look at a
change
like this you know or maybe it's it's a
little bit shocking because
um any any time a big change like this
happens and you start federally
settling into like a pattern of
uncertainty
or fear you you really translate it
within your current context
um but the the game will continue to
evolve and continue
to shift the the shift from um
the shift into rollock it it changed
some of the some of the meta of the game
um and now people look at the role of
of or all of the roles a little
different than they did
than they did previously and i think
that that is a natural result of
something like this and so
it might be easy to say like well i'm an
off-tank player
how is this going to affect me as an
off-tank player
and i get that there are there's
strategy there and there's synergies
between some of these tanks but
if you're an off-tank player if if
you're a diva player or a zarya player
you can still be a diva or a zarya
player and what we're hoping is
is when you get in the game because a
lot of this is about how it
feels to play those heroes when you get
in and actually feel what it's like to
play as
as zarya or diva you'll come away um
really enjoying the experience yeah i
think one thing you mentioned which is a
really good shot is that
yeah like you're you kind of view this
in the context of like how you have it
now right where you're like well wait
like if i just had
no 5v5 today like how would i how would
i do like zarya or you know
how it may work but uh i think to some
of the stuff that you guys have spoken
to especially you jeff like
there's just so many changes that go on
with the heroes that
are involved with this that yeah like i
i think to your point erin like you
really
once you get a feel of it that's when
you really kind of it sets in
yeah it's and it is a big overhaul we
get that it's a
that it's a big overhaul but at the same
time
it still feels like overwatch when
you're playing overwatch
like the heroes all still feel amazing
and incredible you have these
great plays there is still a ton of
strategy
for your team and everybody on it um
to use and so i understand that it's a
big change but this is still like
this is still the same game that that
we've been playing all along
yeah it keeps all those core aspects
that everybody loves about overwatch
but they're just yeah just kind of like
changes a little bit of the core and
push it
forward uh the final map we have today
uh
dion and uh that when we were going over
like what are we gonna show today and
like some of the maps
i was like this map needs to be last uh
because they
just like absolutely stunning uh monte
carlo talk to me a little bit about it
okay so monte carlo and another map
where
it's this beautiful opulent
the wealthy and the overwatch universe
go here to play you know
flying yachts casinos luxury hotels
ai f1 races it's it's
we're another map we're having a lot of
fun just
applying this overwatch aesthetic to the
world and the
this universe and monte carlo or monaco
so and this also has a nice story
connection to the overall
um story of overwatch too so look out
for that as uh
we share more later but yeah it's
it's just gorgeous i mean and the one
thing that strikes me about this
map and i i think you guys can obviously
speak to the best
is that each point and area of the map
plays so drastically different
uh you know once we'll actually see it
in play but
uh is that something that you guys are
looking at with map design of just like
how you
guys can change like verticality levels
of terrain really
you know empower certain heroes or
certain roles to really kind of take
advantage of that
we're definitely doing that and i think
a lot of the overwatch 2 maps
have features in them that that we
haven't built before
um everyone just got a look at rome
and we have that sort of um sort of like
switchback
section in it or or like the the loop
section and that was something
we tried three or four times over the
entire course of overwatch development
development
and we're just never able to get it to
work right and
and on rome we feel like we finally
cracked the code on something like that
um in in monte carlo there is this
really cool
uphill section in the map um and it's
it's steeper and longer than anything
we've done before
um and so there's a lot of um like
difference in elevation there
um and i feel like it it kind of just
speaks to
um some of the some of the changes that
we're willing to make
um with this game in order to introduce
new gameplay
and to have it feel fresh and and
vibrant for players
yeah i definitely think we can start off
that final map we can keep this
discussion going because
that was one of the first things that i
noticed about this map i was like oh
like we're going we're going straight i
was like oh this feels like you know
very like
you know classic overwatch like here
here's the choke and then all of a
sudden we're going up and i was like i
i can't remember a map you know maybe
even i think people when they see it
probably would compare to like i know
ike involved when you're kind of going
around the castle but it's even steeper
than that
like uh you know i remember you know
you're looking at it and you're like oh
man how were they getting up there
like it's such a cool dynamic though
yeah definitely and um ike involves a
great example of it but
of of rising through a map but this one
doesn't have
a large structure in the middle of it so
you're you're going up this really big
elevation and it's all
open and so there's a lot more interplay
between the two teams as they're trying
to push up
up the hill and i i love d on the the
spawn rooms
uh with the cars and everything it's
just so
cool as uh yeah you just kind of see
both of these teams uh
you know come out of the spawn just a
lot of detail i love leaning into the f1
uh when you have like the kind of car
going around the track
uh even the checkpoints is being you
know kind of like your uh
your kind of checkpoint how they would
be in like a race
as yeah you see this so this first point
is uh
really interesting i i think for a lot
of people is
where we'll see zarya on defense it's
like a a solo tank
like you can you can play so many
different ways right uh
well i've i've seen people play like
really close up by like some of these
staircases
a little bit further back you can play
the snipers up on the bridge you can
play
like soul drop on the bridge i think uh
just adds so much more dynamics to play
yeah and you can see the um payload is
uh another
we're having fun with playload here as a
ai driven
f1 car or race
you know you know creating the the
escort maps how does that different from
you know some of the other things you
guys are working on
you know like push uh you know like uh
you know hybrids controls like
uh is there a different type of
philosophy when going in to start like a
map uh you know for escort or some of
those other modes
yeah there's a lot of a lot of
differences between these types of modes
and
when you when you do map design on
overwatch like one of the things you
always have to think about is where the
spawn rooms are going to be and how
you're going to
get out of the spawn rooms and obviously
it's it's different coming out of a
spawn room is different on a payload map
than any of our other map types
because you immediately start
interacting with the objective
um the one of the toughest things about
developing
payload maps for overwatch is the entire
route needs to be
like a certain minimum width just to be
able to get the payload to fit through
and usually you want to have enough
space
on the sides of it so that you can move
around there we do have
a few tight sections in our maps but
they're very short like right after you
get the payload in king's row it gets
very tight but that's
that's for a short period of time and so
when you do start making these wider
areas
it becomes very difficult to control
sight lines and it gets
it gets easy to make very long sight
lines through the map where
it no longer really feels like an
overwatch map
anymore because we really try to control
those things i mean it's i think it's
why you see that a lot of the payload
maps
they they do weave back and forth a lot
and so much of that is about controlling
sight lines and then also presenting
like
difficult areas for for a team to push
through oh this is the hilly section
yeah so i was gonna say that's the
that's the area of verticality where
like uh there's a sniper perch up here
it's kind of like that uh you know
right hand side if we're looking at it
but yeah just uh this poses so many
different obstacles
for teams but i also think it's it's
kind of presents
multiple ways to play where you see
right now
both teams playing zarya but like you
could play really fast and kind of dive
up onto the high ground like you can
play really slow
kind of work your way around so
this team is just actually kind of just
rolling on through
zarya seems to be the tank choice of the
day
yeah and so that change is pretty new
you can see from a visual standpoint
when making a payload map
they're pretty large maps for an
overwatch space so we want the visuals
to kind of change as players
complete objectives the world looks
different to them you know
there was it was flat before and then
you reached the first objective and now
you're on the hill
and they'll move into the hotel for the
final objective so there's this visual
progression
to kind of your completing objectives
you feel like you're making progress
through the map because the world around
you is somewhat changing
as it goes along kind of like uh like
dorado almost like right
think of uh you know a map from the live
game where you
kind of start through that choke area it
goes towards that high ground and then
you have that like
interior and the interior for this map
is one of the cooler things that i've
seen uh in
overwatch and uh hopefully we'll get to
see it but
just the the tiering of it uh how how
did that come about with uh
when we go inside we'll obviously have a
better view of it but
it's really kind of like this
multi-tiered vertical
kind of like casino it's so interesting
yes it's a super cool space and really
fun to fight through i think
you know over time overwatch map design
has changed a little bit just the way
that the game has changed a little bit
um the the presence or the importance of
high ground
really can't be understated in this game
um and so we're trying to give
more of that to teams and trying to
create
kind of like conflict points in some of
these maps and who's going to control
that hydra
yeah no i i think obviously it's a a
shooter
right their high ground is always kind
of the
the go-to uh where
overwatch has always had the ability for
you know multiple players to take high
ground whether it's like a hanzo like we
just saw there like the wall climb or
widow but
yeah with like a multi-tiered level like
this it allows everybody to kind of have
a some axis of high ground
which brings into play i know ana really
kind of effective here at the high
ground with the
grenades as uh we see the payload kind
of go over the line and
the the car will go inside of the casino
uh
i've seen a few cars inside of casinos
they're usually they're usually not
moving though
you know depending on how the day went
maybe they're moving but that's just
from my point of view
uh
this is the hotel portion of the casino
yeah the luxury
yeah you can see the high ground in the
back over there it's actually really
difficult for us to put a lot of it
into our game um one of the things we do
in overwatch
is um our stairs are very shallow
and we don't typically have any steep
ramps in the entire game
and i think the game plays better that
way it feels smoother like that
but it makes it so hard it just
kills the level designers on the project
trying to get people up to high ground
um because it takes a lot of space in
order to do it
oh yeah that's actually a really
interesting point that i guess i
i've never really kind of taken a uh
kind of a notice of yeah when you
like yeah the stairs aren't very like
these like long like windy climbs like
there's kind of turns to get to that
elevation
uh is that just to keep everything
smooth and just kind of
move and predictable yep so that's part
of it so keep it smooth keep movement
predictable
um it's it's also like it can be
um really like kind of um
difficult to overcome a really steep
staircase it's almost like a wall
in front of you you don't know what's
going to be at the top of it and so
we always like for players to be able to
run through our maps and to be able to
look at a space and kind of develop a
mental 3d image
of where everything's going of of what
the space is actually
going to be like outside of their view
and it's easier to do that
with shallower stairs it's also easier
to push up
a shallower staircase in a higher
staircase and like lastly
just the way that a lot of games
character physics work
um it's also smoother to move on
steve staircases or on on shallow
staircases
it's gonna say the only the only really
i guess deep staircase i can think of
is uh the one on like horizon lunar
colony uh
you know on the first point where you're
kind of going up towards the balcony
and yeah that that does kind of prove
like the some of the things that you're
talking about where
i know we've all been there where
junkrat is sitting on top of the stairs
with horizon you can't see where he's
shooting you from and you're just kind
of getting
pelted on the way up uh it's not the
best of feelings you know
yeah uh yeah i don't i don't really know
what to say about that besides
um we are moving away from 2cp
[Laughter]
keep the keep the combat moving i love i
love this area like you see where that
soldier is sitting
up top like one of the cool things about
uh this map that i definitely saw when
watching it was that like
the attackers can actually like access
that area like you can go around uh
wherever you see
it up there yeah curly mustache uh
rotating around
uh and and it's connected uh
that's something we haven't really seen
in a lot of overwatch maps yeah we tried
it
we're very intentional with the way we
do flanking routes and we we try to make
it so that
at least one team like the team can be
aware of
people that are coming on a flank um
and we usually don't try to let you get
all the way around behind the defense
without having
some way of knowing that it's coming or
having the offense earning something
like that
and we think this one's fair we've gone
back and forth on this a lot there there
there's been
30 different variations of this route
but
hopefully this one's fair depending on
how your game goes it's fair or not
preventing who else is in the test
um i actually have some questions from
uh twitter that uh you know
some people have been uh pulling and
just kind of
uh just really i think things that
people are interested in uh
for you guys what changed to uh you know
character
buff or nerf you guys most looking
forward to that you guys have
uh played around implemented with thus
far
wow i mean that's a that's um it's a
great
question you know to ask yesterday but i
think
now that we've gone over um gone over a
lot of what we've been working on
there's
so many changes to characters all across
the board
um and including all the big changes to
to the tank roll the hero passives that
we're introducing with with
all the other roles in in the game so um
as well as like the
the some of the the work that we've been
doing um
uh with uh like cc abilities in the game
so
it's really hard to pick one of those uh
my personal one is actually the one that
we saw from blizzcon wine
was the reinhardt stuff uh yeah as
somebody who's always wanted to play
reinhardt who's pretty tragic at it
uh being able to be a little bit more
this is like selfish
uh being able to be a little bit more
brawly and more offensive
uh is the type of reinhardt play i want
uh on you know when i just charge in
without
talking any of my teammates currently
now you can do that
i'm sure i'm sure that won't work in
overwatch too either but i can at least
put it in my mind that it could be a
possibility
yeah that's always the promise of
reinhardt
um in any version of overwatch that
you're playing is that moment
where you get to drop the shield and go
in and just start laying waste
to people feels so good yes
you know you play reinhardt and you come
out and you feed a few times you're like
maybe maybe this isn't for me and then
you just land that one shatter
that that perfect shatter and then
you're just like yup i'm committing
it's it's such a it's such a good uh
ability here's another one uh
from uh twitter uh that uh how do you
guys uh look at maintaining
the the balance between pvp and pve
i assume they're kept like completely
separate like different environments
like
but how do you guys how do you guys look
at that yeah that's
a really interesting question because uh
we talked a lot about that earlier we
started developing you know much larger
pve games
you know look at a pair like winston
winston is
super fun in pvp but a lot of his
enjoyment comes from
sort of how much you're willing to
commit and there's always like this
risk game you're playing and you're
taking space but are you
you know you don't want to be too far
ahead of your team or your healers and
how you're committing and everything but
it's hard to translate that to pe
environment for example
so that in our early play testing pve
was sort of like
he feels like he needs more and then we
started getting into like okay well we
really need to talk about if we're gonna
keep these separate or are we just
making changes to the face zero um
so a lot of the like for instance that
the current winston alternate fire he
has where he could shoot that blast
actually came from pve first we were
just like
oh this is a lot more fun and like oh i
wonder if this could apply
to the base kit plus we're doing all the
other chains of pvp and i also started
playing with it in pvp so
in those cases like if it feels like it
works and we like enjoy playing it yeah
we'll totally take it but i think
our general philosophy is try to keep
them separate um just so we can
make sure that they shine really great
on both
both the individual game or all the
gameplays really yeah
i have to mention one thing really quick
because it's kind of fun
i did um early on i just had to make
this this
prototype but i did a prototype of like
a pvp ve mode i called it which was like
a
hybrid mode because i think like i i get
the expectation that people will
probably ask about that pretty quick
if we want to do that and so i was like
let's just try it try him out of it and
it was a little dirty because it was
like there wasn't a lot of balancing
done it was just like oh let's just
throw all the crazy pv
stuff in here and see how they work
against players and it was pretty tragic
but uh
it was pretty interesting and like
there's maybe a version of that
yeah exactly this may be a version that
we could do with at some point in the
future we don't have like the right
plans for that right now because it was
one thing came out of it like this is
fun but like man this would be a lot of
work trying to
balance this anywhere close to what it
would have to be
we do a lot of experimentation like that
um
which i think is one of the funnest
parts about working on this game and
i know like oh as as they were playing
rome you know there was a question of
like hey are we working on
like do you work on other game modes and
it is something that we do a lot
actually the push map or the push game
mode came out of a whole different game
mode
that that we were working on um as we
were kind of trying to
solve how you would put um a capture the
flag into like a main version
of overwatch we weren't really able to
do it
but push kind of came out of that um and
we are
we are working on one other one that i'm
really really excited
about um and hopefully it's something
that we'll be able to talk to
talk to our players in the community
about later
i love that yeah more ways to play is
totally fine with me and i'm sure the
rest of the community
uh well it's uh something that i've
actually kind of like
found throughout the day and you know
it's one of the things that's like a
little bit newer to the live games like
the experimental card and then some of
the things you're able to do there
and try out the things that look like
they've kind of made their way in
uh i feel like that has been a huge tool
for you just kind of testing out
the april fools stuff uh you know jeff i
don't know if i can convince you to
give me the flying sigma i don't know
how that works
but like me flying sigma so i can just
battle pharah's and ignore my team but
uh
a lot of some of that stuff is really
interesting that you guys are able to
try with the experimental
yeah it's been so powerful i mean i feel
like
it's sort of a developer dream in a
sense to be like because you're always
just like
i don't know maybe this is kind of cool
can we just like show this to people and
get their impressions
yeah we can't really in fact we've
talked about in the past about expanding
maybe even showing more stuff but um you
know like
what if we showed like crazy early level
layouts that was just all like gray box
stuff
like how early can we show before it
gets like really ridiculous we were just
like
here's a you know a stick man like is
that just like
not even worth getting feedback on or
what but like um
so it's it's it's been powerful and
we're still looking at ways to sort of
use it and
you know it's just another great
feedback tool to get from the community
what's so funny we were talking the
other day and it's like the april fool's
patch was ridiculous but then when
like you saw like some of the community
this is kind of cool you're just like
wait no
like like we get the sigma is cool to
fly for a day or two but like we can't
have that all the time
right so
yeah so we see the blue team kind of
approach
the the final uh area and then uh there
was one question actually just about uh
the overwatch dev team like uh how has
it been you know
uh working from home how large has the
team
gotten over the last few years i feel
like it's it's really grown a lot
um the it's that that work from home is
a bit of a mixed bag
you know um and when we first when we
first started
we were really worried about how
productive the team would be because
it's
never something it's something we
haven't really done before
um and we the team is amazing
and they actually like really rallied
and i feel like we are
um just as productive as we were before
and in some ways
we we are more productive about certain
things you know um
it's it's definitely there's parts of it
that are harder you know like
we don't all have home offices you know
like i'm just i just work in my bedroom
you know i just have to make sure i make
my bed every day before i
go on calls um and then the team
it's um it's really grown we we we um
kind of like when we shipped overwatch
one when it launched we were around 60
to 70 people
and the team has continued to grow um
from there and i don't think we're
at quite 200 yet but we just keep
growing because
this the game that we're making now
overwatch too it's a
much bigger game than the original ones
it's even a bigger game than like even
when i started to hear about overwatch
too it was like oh
like yeah like this is gonna i i want
another overwatch and then
like just kind of hearing everything
that goes involved with it with like the
pve
and i know now all these massive changes
to pvp like
the the scope of the game is so big yeah
it's it's huge um but that's it's
really exciting working on something
that has that many
aspects to it and the thing that that i
like about it and hopefully what we're
showing here today is
that we're able to work on something
that's new you know and it has all these
exciting elements
while still focusing on what like
made the original game great like we're
we're
like hey love or hate um
5v5 we are committed to to
like keeping the pvp of overwatch
as competitive um as possible and we are
putting
so many resources into it yeah just
pushing the game forward it's like all
the heroes that you love
from overwatch one with the learnings
from overwatch one just
evolutionized right you know pushing
pushing the game forward you know coming
up with new kind of creative
ways to play so this this transcendence
may seal the deal
yes reaper reaper did his dance on the
cart and
he was gone that kind of concludes uh
i'm sure i'm sure the the devs are going
to
they'll know who won and lost uh i was
not keeping score of the matches
uh i'm sure they'll be they'll be pretty
angry that we didn't keep score
of uh who won and lost but uh just
just a really awesome showcase of the
the pvp
side of the game today uh you guys could
just kind of give uh one lasting message
to like everybody out there who's
playing overwatch one interested in
overwatch two with all these pvp changes
today what would it be i i guess i'd
one i'd say thank you so much for
watching
um and thank you so much for like the
the support
and the communication like the active
communication
that has been present from our community
ever since um
even from before overwatch came out so
one i'd like to just give a heartfelt
thank
thank you to to everyone that's watching
and has been involved in our communities
throughout the years and
i also want to let you know that we
we are still listening and and we are
still
taking feedback on this game and more
than anything
we just want it to be the best version
of itself um
that it can be and we're committed to to
making it
that we we come into work every day um
kind of like passionate and excited to
to work on this game um whether it's um
some of the some of the things in hero
mode that we're doing for
for the pve side of the game or whether
it's the
the maps or or heroes that we're working
on for the pvp side of the game so
thank you all thank you for letting us
build this game for all of you
because we love doing it uh how about
for you uh jeff and dion
as i pretty much echo what aaron said of
course thanks to community i mean we
a lot of this kind of changes especially
all this experimentation
and things we've done starting overwatch
too was directly getting feedback from
the community and hearing
what people liked and didn't like and
hopefully that that that comes across um
also to mention that
um obviously i i think i've thrown out a
lot already but this is all like pretty
early work in progress still
we're still trying a lot of stuff
there's a lot of stuff that i mentioned
that isn't even in this so you can see
that we're very actively working on this
stuff um so if you like see something
like you know i see doomfist running
around and
you know smash people against walls and
i can imagine somebody like oh doofus is
still
doing his you know some kind of kill but
like you know
i suspect we'll be making a lot of
changes to him for example especially cc
changes so
um it's sort of like the double-edged
sword of like being able to show you
guys the stuff really early is you know
some of it's not quite done yet but um i
think it's it's been awesome to really
um
you know try to keep communication
communication up and letting you guys
see what working on
yeah and i echo the same thing um we
have a pretty incredible team working on
the game the character team world
building
qa production concepting
it's quite a crew we love playing the
game every day and we look forward to
getting it into players hands soon
you know i uh you know obviously kind of
uh you know we're working with you guys
on some of the stuff like this and then
some of the other members of the
overwatch team
like your guy's passion to just make
this game the best is something that
comes through in every conversation so
really excited to see what you guys have
uh in store for the future of the game
uh aaron what's next uh what can
you know the community look for i think
you guys have an ama going on
yup we have one coming up in just a few
days um it's going to be on the the main
overwatch reddit um or subreddit sorry
um so tune in to that
and um i think it's the three of
us don't quote me on that he's signing
up dion for it
if it's not you guys you just just just
got signed up
i'll send the uh aaron let me know
someone's gonna be there answering
questions we'll send the outlook invites
no we'll get everybody in here counting
again
like we did this morning nothing will be
needed for that but uh yeah and then we
have uh
overwatch league uh kicking off again
tomorrow
uh we'll be discussing a lot of the
things that were talked about today here
at
11 30 p.t and don't forget guys the
overwatch anniversary event is going on
right now in game
some really awesome skins uh to earn you
can get that combat uh
you know the the new honest skin i know
by
uh winning games or you can just keep
losing games constantly and eventually
get it just
way slower uh thank you guys so much
uh for everything today uh truly a blast
uh thank you aaron uh jeff and dion
that'll be
from us uh follow play overwatch on all
social medias to stay up with all the
latest news for overwatch 2.
we'll see you next time thanks guys
thank you
time
thanks
uh
right
[Music]
[Music]
oh
um
[Music]
help me
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you